closing arguments have wrapped in the
trial of kyle rittenhouse and i believe
the deliberations will start tomorrow
and boy was today insane
before i tell you how insane it was i
must point out for those that are
watching the live show we are here in
our mobile studio that's right we are on
site in austin we have a bun we have a
crazy show tomorrow with the most people
we've ever had on the show because we're
insane and it's going to be a cacophony
of crazy crackpot nonsense from a lot of
awesome people so this is going to be
awesome awesome with us down in austin
and we're planning on doing more trips
like this so that being said let's let's
carry on with you know you now you
understand why we're in the mobile
studio
let me just tell you my friends
during the trial uh uh today the closing
arguments
the prosecutor
picked up the ar-15 i believe actually i
don't i think it's an mp5 i'm not sure
it's an ar-15 style rifle they call it
chambered in 2-2-3
points it at the jury with his finger on
the trigger aims
i couldn't believe it i i actually
believe the prosecutor should be
criminally charged and i'm not
exaggerating
this is deeply irresponsible we just had
the alec baldwin story come out and the
prosecutor points a rifle at the jury
now i'm gonna stop right there and say
you know what personally i can't believe
it i do not believe it i've seen the
pictures of him pointing the rifle but
we can't see the jury because the jury
their identity is protected but we've
got more than one source saying he
pointed the rifle at the jury finger on
the trigger
oh geez
we gotta talk about what went down in
these closing arguments because the
prosecution was lying through their
teeth now i'll be the first to admit i'm
biased for the defense and there are
some things about what they've said that
i've questioned why i should believe
them i mean that legitimately but i
think the videos speak for itself and
you know what i don't need to speculate
we've got drew hernandez sitting right
here
thanks for having me tim let's do it you
were actually a witness in the trial a
defense witness you were there on the
ground you're a journalist filming it
they tried to smear you on the stand
then they used you as some veteran
reporter then they tried smearing you
again so people that were paying
attention today it's pretty shocking i
mean i'm watching this live on tv and
i'm just like
so in the closing arguments with binger
he tried to discredit me during my
eyewitness testimony under oath by the
way under oath right this was a couple
days ago but in his closing argument
today
he he called me a veteran of covering
protests right but then the other
prosecutor towards the end of the
closing argument tried to discredit me
again for hiring the specific lawyer
that i hired for myself so i truly do
wonder
if the jury is paying attention to this
stuff because i mean he really is
insulting their intellect he really is
insulting their own ability to choose
for themselves because when i was there
i want to say this real quick before we
continue so everybody knows
the reason why i was there was not to
share my opinion i was not some kind of
expert to just speak on the video
evidence or anything like that i was an
eyewitness to what happened
to what i saw while at the same time i
had body cam footage to corroborate
everything that i said so just for the
record because the world is watching
they've been watching on tucker they've
been watching everywhere my bias was the
truth and what i saw that night i was
not there to give any kind of political
opinion that's what i was doing this is
what we need to get into too because
when you tell the truth they say you're
biased and right-wing absolutely because
the truth doesn't serve their narrative
exactly all right we'll get in all that
stuff we got the standard we got we got
the the crew here we got luke and ian
yep i mean first of all texas is awesome
i love it here second of all welcome
everyone to the rv life i've been doing
this for like a year and a half i have
my studio in my rv i love it in there
and uh thanks so much for having me if
you want to support me you can by
purchasing t-shirts the one i'm wearing
right now says fyi the government is way
deadlier than any virus and if you
understand history and what democide
actually means
i think that is an accurate statement
and you could purchase this t-shirt by
going to thebestpoliticoshirts.com
that is my website and uh it does smell
like a little bit of a dmt and graphene
here but i think that's because ian's
sitting right next we're so close to
each other yeah we are very close
together okay i can corroborate what
you're saying man texas is the bomb it's
fresh air clean uh dry i love the heat i
love the the cool and uh the studio
looks great tim you look good you got a
nice pink on your skin there and i see
you got a guitar hanging out next to you
i'm very excited to get moving we're
still doing some uh some tech behind the
scenes to get everything smoothed out we
we did some trial runs but you have to
at a certain point a trial one doesn't
do enough because you know then we add a
bunch more people and then there's
levels we got to figure out you know
some people are quieter than others some
people are louder luke just screams all
the time
no i never do that welcome back we also
we also uh we got lightweight cameras so
they can be more easily mounted but
they're lower quality so i think we can
find a
happier medium and upgrade and probably
do a little bit better but right now
we're at 720. yeah we're streaming in
720 and the cameras themselves don't
display all that well in low light so
they have the bigger cameras with better
sensors
are too heavy for the wall mounts
because we're actually in a really small
space we need to wall mount the cameras
but
hey look it's working and we're here and
we are streaming so let's let's get
started before we do before before that
i want to remind everyone the lydia's
right right behind me perch behind ian
you can kind of see me in ian's shot so
thank you guys for joining us as we're
being awesome in austin and you can see
the microwave you can't can you right
behind me yeah shout out to them
you can actually see the faucet you can
yeah so i'm sitting in the kitchen where
a woman
why is the only woman in the kitchen
that's the question
i just want to point out real quick too
so this is uh uh we're in a big like 40
foot rv
we were looking at like tour buses and
trails and really expensive stuff that
i'm like man i don't know if we can
afford something like that and they
wouldn't work because they're actually
not big enough so having a trailer
has it has this living room where all of
these couches face each other and
there's a big old tv screen you can't
see the tv screen but it allows everyone
to see the display and the news that you
can see when i pull it up so this this
works really well so now let's pull up
that display they can see this is
timcast.com go and become a member we
have a members only segment coming up
after the show goes up around 11 or so
p.m as a member you are supporting our
fierce and independent journalists and
we recently had a a new requirement we
actually need to hire i think two more
journalists and so when you become
members you are basically creating that
ability for us to hire more people and
we're going to be adding more writers
and reporters we're looking for someone
where we're actually looking for someone
to do to be a white house press
correspondent i don't know if that's a
good idea in the long term though
because it's a stupid position in my
opinion not to be disrespectful but like
the sake is not going to call on you
you're not going to get questions and
she's going to play the game and then
you sit in a room and you report what
everyone watched on the internet anyway
can you put me in there for a day i
would love to be in there i would make
sure i have the front row hands up like
this they don't let you sit in the front
i'll like sit on the on the floor and
it'll be it'll be interesting remember
when cernovich went in there and was
like yelling you're like at the press
yeah they're complicit they're not doing
their jobs start reporting
you actually you know my understanding
is we talked about this it's like but
they're not going to call on you they're
not going to give you what you want but
we're going to we're going to do it and
we're going to do all this stuff we're
we're your membership gets more
journalists more technology and more
members only shows and as you can
you can see on the front page of this
leading covet test firm is planning to
sell swaps containing customers dna oh
my that's right that's the kind of stuff
we're covering the important stuff and
this is this is confirmed rapport i mean
we fact check this stuff go to
timcates.com don't forget to like this
video right now like this stream you're
watching the stream on youtube smash
that like button subscribe to this
channel share the show with your friends
let's go right into the first story this
is it right here it's from the western
journal
the story is written house prosecutor
violates gun safety points ar 15 with
finger on trigger at court full of
people why is this important
the prosecution was actually arguing
earlier on that there was a charge
potentially for kyle rittenhouse because
they claimed he aimed his weapon at
people which is like negligent disregard
for the safety of others some like that
pointing a weapon at people was a
criminal offense they argued now here's
something funny
the prosecutor does this
i don't even know if we can show you the
footage of the photo of it and there's
multiple photos because youtube might
actually give us a strike for showing
him pointing a rifle at people but you
know what we're gonna do it anyway
because this is the prosecutor and if
youtube doesn't even allow us to show
the prosecutor aiming a rifle finger on
the trigger to jury
then
we're in a whole world of hurt with
censorship so here it is
right here on the front of the screen
matt walsh says kenosha d.a pointed a
gun at the jury with his finger on the
trigger there's the image let me let me
let me blow it up let me get a bigger
here's a bigger one for you now this is
from behind this is from one of the
streams where you can see the prosecutor
in the kyle rittenhouse case aiming a
rifle at people now hold on
these photos don't actually show you who
he's pointing at why
because they can't show the jury the
jury's identity is kept secret they mute
the audio when they're talking with the
jury they send the jury in and out and
i'll even point out i
don't believe it i j i'm i'm biased i
cannot believe it that he actually
pointed the rifle finger on the trigger
and i just got to say a couple more
things
here it is this finger on the trigger i
believe i think i have a bigger photo
here look at this
finger on the trigger now there's no
magazine it doesn't matter there can be
a round in the chamber and someone could
easily put it in but i just want to
stress this point people like to talk
about how newsguard is biased it's
microsoft it's bill gates so i'm going
to show you right here western journal
according to newsguard
has an 82 out of 100. the website mostly
adheres to basic standards of
credibility and transparency newsguard
says this is real news and they say the
prosecutor held an ar-15 rifle with his
finger on the trigger and pointed it
toward the jury
that this is definitive now tim i know
you don't believe it i do because number
one he's a government employee number
two he's chicken winging i remember the
first time i held a rifle before
my elbows are all the way up that's not
really the proper way to hold a rifle
you learn to kind of hold them down and
not act like you're doing the funky
chicken so uh i mean obviously i think
he was doing it for
dramatic effect i mean if i was sitting
on the jury we were talking about this
you said you you'd scream because you
have a good point to that you want
someone with the finger on the trigger
let me clarify i wouldn't scream like
i would yell get down and i'd shove
people to the floor there's a government
agent holding a firearm with his finger
on the trigger in your face that he
hasn't checked properly before even
picking up
he didn't even do that he didn't check
it yeah he did it he asked other people
if they did this is baldwin yeah it is
alex baldwin as soon as i see this i was
like was alec baldwin consulting him
that's the question that i asked him i i
have some personal experience with this
guy so i mean my personal experience
with him he seemed totally unprepared
for me when i went to go testify the
other day
and it just kind of seemed like he
wasn't really prepared for what he was
doing in this trial and i can't really
speak for him but looking at something
like this i mean how could you take
someone serious when they're talking
about uh how you handle a firearm or the
do's and don'ts when you're speaking to
the jury when they display something
like this in a courtroom i mean i think
he he was trying to discredit me i think
this discredits himself he had you drew
hernandez reporter on the scene on the
stand as a as a fact witness not as an
expert witness as someone who's like i
was there i saw this and he started
questioning why you had a lawyer he
started questioning whether you were
biased who you worked for now not then
i'm hoping the jury can see through what
this guy has been doing
because
pointing a weapon at them i i think i
understand why he did it he was hoping
that they would feel this fear
and then be like wow is that what kyle
rettenhaus did to people he should be in
jail
he should be in jail not not kyle
rittenhouse
binger should be in jail no no no look
it's i think it's a misdemeanor charge
to point a weapon to british weapon at
somebody
i don't see why he gets special
privileges in a courtroom putting his
finger on the trigger with a weapon he
did not check people are all you see all
these leftists all the i shouldn't say
leftists because leftists like guns
establishment democrats and they're
going to be fair he did ask if it was
unloaded
that that's all he did that that's it
that's not imagine imagine there's a bad
actor they don't like him he's a leftist
and when they when they when they check
the bolt they pop in a two two three and
say you're good to go and then he aims
and bang kills a juror that risk should
not be present in any capacity a bunch
of people i asked as soon as i saw it
happen i said why didn't they lock the
bolt back
just good point lock it back so we know
it's clear it's not gonna fight
dude this is like a really bad video
game like this this this guy the alec
baldwin didn't check the magazine or he
didn't check the the chamber
neither did it and then like two weeks
later this guy didn't check the chamber
and like you said he seemed unprepared
he seemed like a stoner that went to
theater school
like like he was getting really high a
couple weeks ago yeah
and now he's like had it out of his
system for a while because he's got a
big trial up ahead or maybe he's on like
zoloft or something or some crazy like
slowing mechanism that because the guy
is like faded now i want to point out it
says that he pointed it toward the jury
that's different than at the jury so
maybe it's like above the jury down the
hallway past the jury well no no no the
western journal is reporting that he
pointed it directly well no no it says
tord yeah but come on man what does tord
mean yeah in their direction degrees
cone around the target right right i
think that's a fair point but i also
think regardless it's still like if
there's a group of people and you're not
directly aiming at any one person you're
pointing it toward the group dude he
didn't check the chamber at least have a
chamber flag i mean that's even common
sense as well but again
again he works with the government and i
would be i would i'd run away
i want to point this out i want to point
this out here's what here's what i
tweeted i think anybody who knows guns
knows these rules
treat a gun always as if it is loaded
and here's his picture never pointed at
something you don't intend to destroy
keep your finger off the trigger until
you are ready to fire there's one i
didn't include in this
always know where your target is and
what is beyond it so let's make the
argument he didn't actually point it at
a jury with his finger on the trigger
those walls are not going to stop a
rifle round
and he has no idea who's behind those
people or behind that wall or whatever
i think this discredits everything he's
saying about his arguments about guns
about bullets you know the defense made
a really really good point in their
closing arguments
it was richards the defense uh who said
i've been in trials you know the
prosecution tries to call full metal
jacket as if it's a more threatening
round as if it matters he said i've been
in trials where they say you know to the
jury he used hollow points those are
designed to kill people whereas a full
metal jacket would just go through them
and they'd survive and now with carbon
house they're arguing the opposite
hollow points wouldn't have gone through
people and it wouldn't have been
reckless and he says regardless of that
the bullet is a bullet and making an
argument about the kind of bullet
irrelevant and here you have a guy who
tries to act like he knows what he's
talking about he doesn't know what he's
talking about you wanna sing funny i
think it was kraus the other eight the
prosecutor who said there's no such
thing as a right or left-handed gun
it's amazing it's not true how they can
just say things without knowing what
they're talking about
and the funny thing is
i guess you can't actually object to
lies
for real so my understanding is the is
the the opponents can object in your
closing arguments to matters of the
court so there was a moment where
they stated that the zaminsky's it's
like kelly and some other guy was named
zach i don't know i don't remember his
first name
he said they have a fifth amendment
right you know why didn't they testify
they objected to that saying they don't
have a fifth amendment right they could
have called the woman who was convicted
but the dude this is this is a really
important point in the trial
whether or not someone has a fifth
amendment right is up to the prosecution
did you guys know that no you think like
i plead the fifth no the prosecutor can
say then we grant you full immunity
start talking and if you don't you're in
contempt so when they say ziminski could
testify the the state the defense was
like we can't call him he can plead the
fifth but the state can grant immunity
and get whatever testimony they want
from him but they won't and the judge
would not
uh sustain the objection he sort of
sustained it he said we'll just ask you
to move on he didn't explain to the jury
that the state controls the ability of
fifth of of pleading the fifth so now
you have this guy who has no idea what
he's talking about they have power over
some of the witnesses they didn't
execute the search war warren on gage
gross kreutz and they control whether or
not zaminsky even testifies and here's
here's the point this is why it's
important
how written house got the gun charge
dismissed we'll talk about in a second
that's a huge victory but he stated the
prosecution stated that there's a min
he pointed the gun at the ziminskis and
the defense said i don't see the
zaminsky's here and the judge said you
didn't call them as witnesses to testify
on the fact that a weapon was pointed
out there's no complaining witness if i
can't see it happen i can't instruct the
jury that it did
very very important points
hypothetically if if kyle did use hollow
points let's just kind of play up the
scenario i mean the scene would be so
much more graphic than it already was
and already
you saw the state prosecutor play
extremely graphic videos show extremely
graphic images during his closing
arguments that i couldn't even look at
like it like sparked a very strong
reaction to me so i do think when when
he was doing his kind of theatrics
putting his finger on the trigger moving
the rifle around when he was showing you
know the bicep when he was showing the
gore when he was showing the blood i i
think he was trying to evoke more of an
emotional response rather than a logical
one because other than that i can't
really understand what he was really
trying to do here also there's a meme
video going around from the movie heat
uh with his image state kind of kind of
imposed as the state prosecutor in
action that is also going viral on the
internet and uh i just uh with him with
the rifle yes with him the rifle there's
there there's a lot of people we can't
show it yeah we can't i would i really
wanted to like luke's like look at this
thing i tweeted and i was like we gotta
we can't put that on youtube you know
here's a comment i wanna make about the
trial and the reason why you're seeing
this prosecutor um
look really bad
time after time even
the state's own witnesses right gage
came out and literally admitted under
oath he pointed his gun at kyle first
right the reason why you're seeing this
happen over and over and over again is
because the truth is coming out it's
coming out from the prosecution it's
coming out through the defense as well
and when you find yourself trying to
suppress the truth or you find yourself
trying to dance around the truth or
combat against the truth to try and like
discredit it it's not gonna go well for
you and that's why you see this happen
over and over and over again in this
trial and people are just kind of like
what's going on with this guy what's
what's going on here because it's like
when you're trying to argue with the
truth and you're trying to discredit it
and make it look like it's not even
relevant or true or you just try and
like take the jury away from that's what
he was trying to do with me he's trying
to take the jury away from what i was
going to testify take the jury distract
away ask me questions that would lead me
down another path it doesn't go well for
you and the reason why it doesn't go
well for you is because it all comes out
and when it comes out people are gonna
know for themselves what really happened
that's what's happening this is a big
victory in and of itself that it's
televised because
you know in a real system with just
malicious
malpractice of justice it would be it
would have been behind the scenes
kangaroo court one and done no one would
have seen it but we get to watch all the
malfeasance um i think that's a victory
whatever the outcome of the church
imagine this imagine imagine if no
videographers would have been there that
night oh yeah imagine where we would be
right now you know what's funny is uh
the narrative that's been spun the
president of the united states literally
used kyle rittenhouse as a poster child
for white supremacy in his campaign one
thing i don't think we hear enough is
that after rosenbaum was shot
in .739
of a second he got hit he was shot at
four times
richie mcginnis
did not run with the crowd he didn't
scream he didn't hit the ground why
he had no fear that kyle rittenhouse
would cause him any harm or i shouldn't
say that
his fear did not reach a level to where
he thought he should flee at all maybe
he was like there's some issue but i
genuinely believe
richie ran up to rosenbaum and acted
like kyle wasn't even there
because he knew in my opinion i haven't
talked to him about it he knew that kyle
wasn't a threat to him at all i think
that's the most important point the
second most important point
in this trial when they were watching a
video the judge walks over to the big
screen tv and sits down and watches the
video kyle rittenhouse walks up right
behind the judge and leans in right over
his left shoulder no bailiff no
handcuffs no complaints no one freaking
out no one was threatened by this kid
not a single person because they know he
was only a threat to those attacking him
and lastly
all of you agree with me and i know it
if if ada bingor was on the ground in
kenosha during a riot and he saw kyle
rittenhouse he would run to him for
safety yes
yep well let me tell you something when
i was there that night right and i
testified under oath so i feel
comfortable saying it again because it's
true
when i was there that night the first
time i saw kyle that night they were in
front of a
it was they call it car source two right
the second car dealership right um there
were individuals on the roof they had
rifles on the roof right
and one of them was outside on the
ground as well and this was after the
rioters were going head-to-head with the
police and the police were pushing them
down sheridan pushing them they were
deploying rubber bullets they were
rioting they were taking concrete slabs
and destroying them on the floor and
throwing them at the cops taking
fireworks explosive devices throwing
them at the police vehicles
so as they were getting pushed back when
they got to car source two these guys on
the you know on the building had their
rifles
the rioters came to them they're like
you ain't the police you ain't the
police you ain't the cops you ain't like
getting super confrontational to the
point where the riders went behind car
source two grabbed more rocks more
concrete slabs and were throwing them at
the individuals with rifles on the top
of the building they brought a rock to a
gun fight okay
so the reason why this is important is
the first time i saw kyle was when he
came outside of this car source too and
attempted to de-escalate that situation
and you know what he had his hands like
he was you know he was going like kind
of like when you
uh when you're saying hey like calm down
calm down like like what instead of
saying the word calm down what do you do
you use your hands yeah that's what he
was doing and then the riders dispersed
because they were getting super
confrontational like you ain't the cops
you ain't the police you ain't the
police and then they dispersed so that's
the crazy thing
i've been to a bunch of events we had um
who was who tweeted today that white
supremacists in ferguson do you see that
i can't remember who it was no i don't
want to say the wrong person but you
know someone tweeted did you see that
drew no they were like when we were
marching in ferguson white supremacists
were hiding by the hill where michael
brown was shot and started they were
shooting at us and i'm like
you know i've been there and nothing
like that happened at least nobody said
it happened i didn't experience anything
like that no one i know said anything
like that but not a single activist
report anything like that until today
but the reason i bring that up is i'm on
the ground in ferguson
i watched the oath keepers i filmed the
oath keepers up on top of the building
standing there with weapons
then you we had it was uh um
i can't remember the guy's name um
what's his name it's been a long time
the group comes down and they start
marching down
and it wasn't it wasn't stewart uh they
start walking down the road with rifles
and people are yelling at him just like
that you ain't the police you're not the
cops and the dude i can't remember his
name who's in the front he's like you
know a leader in the earthkeepers he
goes we know we know we're just here for
everyone's safety and they were like
then why aren't you here protecting us
and he goes we are and they're like what
do you what and he's like yeah we want
to make sure the police don't hurt any
of you guys and they went what
we i was i watched him say he was like
he's like we're here like the cops
shouldn't hurt you guys you guys keep
protesting do your thing and we want to
make sure that everyone's safe and they
were like what
the thing about kenosha was it wasn't a
protest
at no point was it a protest i mean i
was in chicago um
the night jacob blake got shot right and
i was looking on twitter and the first
thing i saw the literally one of the
first reports i saw
what was happening in kenosha was the
rioters were already taking brick took a
brick to a police officer's head knocked
him unconscious and then i started to
see other reports and i'm thinking to
myself
how far is kenosha whoa it's like a what
hour and a half two two hour drive it
was like a 300 uber right i don't even
think that's hard i think it's like an
hour i don't remember it was it was it
was far and it was during the lockdown
in chicago at 11 p.m at night i don't
even know how i got an uber
but i took it went there and right when
i showed up they already had dumpster
cars uh dumpster trucks on fire
exploding they were looting they were
dumpster carts like car trucks a
dumpster rocks a truck it's on my
twitter anyone can go watch it right now
drew h live that's one of the secrets
you know a full vehicle the full truck
dumpster truck on fire and uh the ones
who brought rifles to the kenosha riot
first
was actually the rioters
i retweeted that today they were there
night one and they were in a standoff
with the police in the middle of the
street and they had their rifles they
were the ones who brought guns first
that's a fact i watched that video where
it was like a mattress store or
something where it was being burned down
you see the smoke billowing out of the
building do you see that video
i have to look at it because there's so
many burnt buildings and connections
right it's where the old guy is running
up and like trying to get people at his
store and then someone bashes him over
the back of that with a rock and he just
falls down he's lying on the ground
bleeding and they're all like laughing
and hooting at him i have to look at
that one but that night
was a mixture of arson looting
vandalism
total violence they they burnt down
multiple buildings and that's why when
you hear the mainstream media this is
why they'll come out and say oh you're
just biased and they were chanting black
lives matter when they did it okay right
it's all on film and i posted it that's
not bias that's just the truth this is i
was in i was in san jose uh when
what it was it was that moment where the
guy got hit in the back of that with
rocks from the trump rally
and
i tweeted out it was bernie sanders
supporters who did it there was a big
moment where they were like bernie
supporters bernie bros or violent bernie
supporters are violent bernie was like
you guys got to knock it off and i
tweeted like yeah those guys were bernie
supporters and they were like you're a
liar and you're far right and i was like
but that's what happened and they're
like how do you know they were bernie
supporters they were wearing bernie
shirts like they were like wearing
bernie a couple of the people who were
part of the mob had bernie stickers and
stuff on them and they were screaming
and shoving people and i'm like that's
just what i don't know i didn't think it
was that big of a deal to be like oh
yeah this was the left that was in this
behavior at the time i genuinely thought
because i've seen the black bloc tactics
they're proud of the of what they call
the diversity of tactics i didn't
understand why they would all of a
sudden now deny the fact that they beat
people
all the time they were proud of it luke
i mean knows it luke was there when i
got attacked in new york yeah and luke
pulls guy's mask off yeah well me and my
friends
made sure that you know we prevented
further escalations and and you know
you could just see a lot of these
actions unfold right before they unfold
with how people are preparing for it but
again when we look at what happened last
year during the summer we're talking
about over three
dozen people dying so people were
affected people did die people were hurt
people were injured but but and there
were several accounts of this but the
mainstream media picked this particular
case they highlighted it there's a lot
of tragedies out there there's a lot of
responsibility out there that you could
point to so many different people i
would directly point at big tech social
media i would directly point at the
mainstream media that was censoring any
opposing viewpoints promoting
obfuscating or even just sometimes
making excuses for for violence and i
think that was deliberate and i think
we're having that same kind of element
being brought back now it is during the
winter will we see large civil unrest we
don't know the national guard is being
deployed in wisconsin we have the nypd
chicago pd lapd seattle pd washington pd
all mobilizing yeah 500 national guards
all mobilizing their police officers
why are 500 national guard called out to
kenosha tonight if this whole thing
started as a peaceful protest why this
is why i'm so aggressive tim because
they're trying to lie they're trying to
cover for these violent criminals that
literally showed up to literally burn
down buildings threatened the community
kenosha was literally having a massive
threat that night and this is so
underplayed because they want to cover
for these people and make them look like
little saints that they're just
opposing racism they weren't what
happened to kenosha had nothing to do
with jacob blake being shot and you're
biased for for talking about what you
saw and what you filmed that we all
plainly understood and i want to stress
a very important point when they
criticize your bias you actually
testified that you had concerns about
the guys with guns as well yeah the the
prosecutor was like you held up your
press badge when they were pointing a
laser pointer at you because you were
concerned for your safety and you were
like well i'm always concerned for my
safety but he was like but you're
worried they might have a gun on you yes
you said yes to that right this is why i
was trying to explain context in that
situation
that situation i just explained to you
where i saw kyle come out and attempt to
de-escalate a situation that was the
same building
that the rioters were taking rocks and
throwing them at individuals with rifles
on top of the building but but i listen
i was sitting there
filming it so the reason why i said of
course i'm in kind of concerned about my
life because i don't want to be
misidentified with these morons throwing
rocks at people with guns absolutely no
but i think the important point here is
that i'm trying to make is there's two
things one i think it's fair to say
you've you i can't speak for you but
i've been on the ground i absolutely
fear the riders more than i would fear
militia members militia members tend to
have firearms training they tend to mean
more skittish about using force or
weapons and this is true of the left
militias as well when i see when i would
see the armed socialist groups like the
socialist rifle association or whatever
they call themselves
i would feel safer around them as well
because they take it very very seriously
but that being said
when you testified you did have some
concerns about both sides
right he has the nerve to call you
biased but then accuse you of fearing
both the writers and the armed gunman
i'm like
how can the how can the lawyer come to
you and say
the prosecutor i'm sorry you're biased
against those people and you are also
scared about the guys with guns it's
like so which is it who's he biased
against if he's got concern for his
safety across the board it sounds like
he's mostly concerned
for himself and not who's doing what but
that's it you film the riders rioting
and say they're riders he literally
called you biased for saying they were
writers he said your footage seems
slanted towards the rioters and i
responded and said yeah because they're
rioting in the footage absolutely like
it just it doesn't make any sense and
that's why i'm watching the tron i'm
like dude you you're what he's doing is
he's insulting the intellect and the
judgment ability of the jurors
because you see this
you know you see this back and forth
where
i'll use myself as an example today he
literally praised me for being a veteran
reporter trying to add credibility to me
when it fit his little narrative and
then at the end
they literally try to discredit me again
at the end of their closing argument
that just that just to me if i was a
juror that would insult me completely
like so so you think i'm that dumb then
i even pick up on it he he did it on
multiple occasions one of the biggest
ones was him describing the activities
of of rosenbaum and acted like it wasn't
a big deal yeah when he went over
everything that he did hold it up in a
second i don't know if he could play
that including
isn't that funny though isn't it it's
like listen
he's like oh he uses the n word
i want to play this video in a second i
want to play the video yeah it's a lot
we'll get to it we'll get to it
did you want to point out no no
that he contradicted himself when he was
questioning you uh you know drew and
then with his closing arguments he
literally said the opposite of what he
was saying to you so that's that's a
major point here and this video i mean
is just uh
it's just wild man we're gonna play this
video okay i don't know do we have
desktop audio uh pulled up it's the
second or last on the mixer board just
in case
because i don't know if we set up
desktop audio for playback just yet i
think we do but let's play and we'll see
what happens we'll find out
he just happens to stumble in okay wait
okay all right i'm gonna play this but i
wanna give you some context this is
washington free beacon saying
binger says that all rose and bob rosen
rosenbaum did the night of the shooting
was
let me just play for you as he reads off
this list when i heard this video i
screamed i was like wow i'm like in the
vehicle when he said it watching this
live check this out
he just happens to stumble into it
so what does he do that night
oh let me tell you all the awful things
joseph rosenbaum did he tipped over a
porta potty
that had no one in it
he swung a chain
he lit a metal garbage system dumpster
on fire
oh and there's this empty wooden flatbed
trailer that they pulled out in the
middle of the road and they tipped it
over to stop some bearcats and they lit
it on fire oh my god right here right
here oh and he said some bad words right
here said the n-word
okay listen just pause
america america okay america all right
for all the woke supremacists out there
you got you got this white attorney
playing down the use of the n-word being
used by another white guy using the
n-word at a so-called a so-called
anti-racism gathering in kenosha does
that make sense to any of you out there
does it to me okay so for quick context
for those just tuning in this is the
prosecutor in the kyle rittenhouse case
trying i think
to downplay the actions of joseph
rosenbaum who was
i got to be very careful about this yes
a person who committed some of the most
serious atrocities against children and
i do believe that matters in this case
and should have been relevant because he
just got out of jail and that played a
role in why he yelled i don't care if i
go back to jail but i digress we'll get
to that later
it seems like binger the prosecutor is
trying to downplay as if to say he only
did these things and then he got killed
and let me i got to point out
he he slowly escalates it it's like dude
start with the worst thing and end with
the lighter thing
start with like well he did he did
participate in burning up a trailer in
the middle of the street but then what
was he really doing on his own he
knocked over a port-a-potty okay it's
bad but there was no one in it no he
starts with the lightest and escalates
to the point where i'm like what he's
like he knocked over a porta potty i'm
like that's pretty bad but like i've
seen pranksters do that as long as
nobody in it well and he left out what
happened because he said oh he lit a
metal dumpster on fire no it was on fire
and he was attempting to push it into
occupied police vehicles with human
beings inside of them and there there
there were people pushing dumpsters
towards a gas station i want to be
careful how i phrased that because
whether they were trying to i can't read
their right it was like down the road
past the gas station they were moving in
the direction of the gas station but
some set and then the fire got put out
but hold on he goes from there he's
letting a dumpster on fire i'm like whoa
whoa okay that's getting pretty
dangerous what human can get away with
that you can't get away with that stuff
do you remember when the judge
when when they were in pre-trial uh
motions he was like
we shouldn't be able to call them
arsonists all he did was set a dumpster
on fire and the judge goes are you
kidding me
arson that's arson
hold on hold on then he says he was
swinging a chain it's like hold on yo
last i checked fires make more fires
that's like really bad and swinging a
chain you can kill somebody doing that
so he's escalating and then he's like oh
and then he took a wooden trailer and
flipped it over in the street and set it
on fire to block the police and i'm like
yo that's like really bad like that's
blocking emergency service is bad that's
accidentally killing people bad and to
top it all off with cherry on top he's
screaming the n-word over and over again
cool yo it sounded to me like the
prosecutor was trying to lose
and and so i tweeted this the ada krauss
the other prosecutor did a much much
better job than binger people got mad
that i tweeted they're like are you
kidding he's flopping and i'm like i
didn't say he was doing a good job that
guy was doing that guy would laugh at me
he would laugh at me anytime i would say
antifa
rioter arson vandalism and looting he
would laugh at me and just shake his
head like that and i'm like what are you
laughing at
that's funny to you that's why i'm
saying the jury's seeing that stuff
because people are gonna people know
what happened in kenosha and when people
are sitting there laughing at what
happened to their town they're not gonna
have it there there were people who are
super chatting to us uh in response to
your testimony so i guess i don't know
if it's true i don't accuse worker of
saying it but people were saying on
rocket stream they were saying you were
a bad witness and i think some of it has
to do with you came off as adversarial
with the prosecutor right i think he
came off as adversarial with me because
i didn't come in with that mentality i
came in here's the thing and people may
not know this is i submit my footage and
i was willing to cooperate with both of
them
he did not have to approach me that way
but he chose to because he wanted to
make it seem like it was adversarial but
i kept stating over and over again i'm
willing to tell both sides the truth and
i'm here for the jury i personally i'm
not a lawyer so i can only defer i think
raketo does a great stream if you guys
haven't been watching his stream and
stuff the commentary is absolutely
fantastic hearing all these lawyers tell
you about what's right what's wrong and
when you have like 10 lawyers who are
watching they can point out all of the
mistakes being made it's great it's kind
of unfair to the actual defense team
because they don't have the privilege of
having 10 other lawyers advising them or
whatever but anyway it was a great
stream but but i will say i actually
thought you i i think he may have gotten
you the prosecutor in that regard i
think you're right
he knew that you were a fact witness on
the ground and you were
very good for the defense so he had to
try and figure out a way to make it seem
adversarial you being confident in what
you are talking about he he does this
really annoying thing where he was like
um
oh who do you work for you uh don't
don't aren't you being biased it's like
a very annoying and condescending
because he wants you to be like
hey look this is what happened so that
he can make it seem like you're not
credible that being said i thought yo
one thing that you said was the most
important bit of testimony that people
shouldn't gloss over when you brought up
that cal right now came out and
de-escalated the violence yep because we
can make we can question the actions
that night all day we can say should
kyle have run did he point the rifle
they're trying to claim this video and
we can have an argument over the facts
surrounding rosenbaum chasing him
but when you brought up that you
witnessed kyle say please you know i i
mean uh i'm paraphrasing i'm i'm using a
metaphor like when he came out trying to
calm people down that says to me there
is no way you can argue intentional
homicide well here's another point and
this is why i don't care about any of
the lawyers that are doing their live
streams critiquing me and any of that
none of that means anything to me
the reason why is because not only was i
there to share my eyewitness testimony i
was there to submit more than 80 to 100
videos that corroborate every single
thing that i said everything that i said
and i don't care who has them
on planet earth right now other than
those jurors and that's why i was there
and i have faith in the jurors that they
were going to listen to my testimony and
they have all of those videos to take a
look at what really happened at least on
my part from my heart from my
perspective in my own life my own
conscience that's what that was my
intention to be there for this case i
was
i was flabbergasted
how often the prosecution lied
bingo and krause and their closing
arguments kept lying and and some of it
was just falsehoods which could be
accidental but some of it was outright
lies completely contradicting what the
judge said there is no duty to retreat
uh avoidance is not a category maybe i'm
wrong maybe i was watching this and i
even i even checked on this i looked up
to make sure
there's four categories i don't know
what the four categories are but some
states have a fifth avoidance i want
i've been reading andrew branca's law of
self-defense because he's a self-defense
expert but avoidance means in certain
places you have a duty to retreat not
wisconsin but they kept saying he had a
duty to retreat he should have he didn't
exhaust all methods he could have run
even though he did run but it was
amazing to watch them just outright lie
and i thought to myself how is it
that the prosecution the state is
allowed to lie to the jury when the when
the defense would object this is the
craziest thing there was one point
where
binger has the rifle and he's explaining
that he pointed it you know because he
did this in more than one occasion i
guess but he he he pointed it at the
zaminski's
and then the the uh the defense objects
he's facing the wrong direction and
before the judge says anything bingo
goes that's an argument
and then the judge goes yeah that is an
argument i'm like whoa
the arrogance of the prosecution
i don't understand how they can admit
cgi evidence which they did like this is
not a photograph they admitted computer
generated imagery of the night in
question
and then claimed that kyle written house
in a split second dropped a fire
extinguisher took off his weapon put the
strap back on it and then aimed it with
his left hand with the with the chamber
right next to his face so it would eject
a cartridge into his face that's what
the prosecution claimed
i and then and the argument is i guess
the way the court works is well the
defense can just tell the jury that when
it's their turn and i'm like no way man
if you have a false statement of fact i
personally maybe i'm wrong because i
don't understand why they do it this way
and there's probably a good reason but
i'd imagine a good judge would be like
make your arguments but don't make up
your facts there are left-handed weapons
and it is true that you were facing the
wrong direction in your demonstration
you can make an argument about intent
about what kyle should have done but he
shouldn't be allowed to say there's no
such thing it was kraft said there's no
such thing as a left-handed gun
of course there are latino guns there i
i there's i have um
which one is it what's what's my polish
makarov whatever it's a right-handed gun
it is specifically only a right-handed
weapon and there are left-handed weapons
i know because i have a right-handed gun
you literally you can hold it your left
if you are left-handed but it's
uncomfortable and it's not shaped
properly i just don't get it
maybe we should have a lawyer on to
explain to me why prosecution has been
allowed and maybe the real reason is
because the defense didn't object but
also bingo and i brought this up to you
guys before the show uh he makes
statements you're supposed to be asking
the witness questions but he will say
things like it seems to me that he
said that if you light a fire that he's
going to use his weapon is that correct
his question is is that correct
before he makes a giant statement about
what he believes is happening that to me
is court mouth it's malpractice i i
think the the the prosecutor's not
supposed to
makes directed statements to the
witnesses it's a true feed them it is
and it's it's lazy uh law practice when
there have been a few instances where
the judge there's been an objection
and like the defense said that's a
statement and then the judge goes ask a
question
that's common they'll do that but you're
right it is extremely lazy but it's
probably on the line where it's like so
ian when you walked down the street you
really wanted to kick that dog
right
exactly it's like no i just said you
wanted to do it then asked you to agree
with me you know what i mean yes the
questions are do you agree do you agree
do you agree not not and this is i mean
it is so blatant at 116 39 or whatever
and the i wish we had the video pulled
up he makes a long statement and they
cut him off in the middle of it before
he has a chance to say is that is that
accurate what channel are you on this is
the actual full video prosecutors
cross-examinate cross-examine kyle
rittenhouse on youtube 116 39 time stamp
uh banger just goes into a long
statement and then they cut him off and
he's like i'll withdraw the question
they object to it and then he says i'll
withdraw the question in the right after
he just made a statement
it's not a question but it's a good
thing they objected and that's that's
the part of the process but even the
defender was like that's something
something the question the judge was
like yeah you can't they're like you
gotta take back your question that was
the bad question it was like dude it was
a statement this is what the
prosecution's been doing they've been
what he did to me yes what he did to you
that their whole case is predicated upon
emotional manipulation they claim drew
hernandez is this veteran reporter who
knows what he's talking about when it
serves the current argument for this
minute and then later on at the end of
the argument they say he's biased you
can't believe him when he kept like he
would use and i know lawyers do this but
i think he just was unaware that i would
actually pick up on it like he would say
things like
so this video you posted um that you
made on and he would continue like no i
didn't make anything
oh
and this was on video he's like oh the
video you recorded
yes
so these words matter because they could
lead you down a path to get you to admit
to something without even realizing
because he was trying to what he was
doing was
you had two clips
you had one you had one moment captured
on two different cameras so you
basically just put one and then the
other right
and he tried using it to argue it was
manipulated videos he used the word
splice exactly that's why when he was
like you made the video he was trying to
get you that's why i'm like people need
to realize that i think i think you did
a good job i mean i'm sure there's some
things people could criticize you for
but if you went there told the truth you
were yourself that's all that matters
but he was he tried to say you made the
video and you caught him on that because
his line of questioning was you spliced
the video and you manipulated therefore
we should be allowed to use our
manipulated video as well but that's why
if you guys caught my response my
response was
there's full footage on the body cam and
the phone unedited i sent you all the
raw and i sent you this
synced video as well so the jury has all
of it the other thing he said was i
loved this because the night before you
testified i was like drew is not going
to take it from him he's not going to be
manipulated he's going to know what he
knows he's going to say what he said
because we've had you on the show i know
the kind of person you are and he said
you went down to kenosha to film the
things that were happening there and
you're like the violent riots yes yeah i
was like yeah
yeah because they're trying to they're
trying to omit that
from to keep it from the jury and they
need they need to know that this was not
some peaceful environment they they're
trying to paint this picture that you
know someone showed up to kenosha on
some random day and just decided to
shoot somebody or they're even trying to
say someone showed up to kenosha at a
peaceful protest and decided to shoot
somebody that's not true this is what's
getting me
at all from what i've seen i i can't
visualize the violence like like how
many buildings do you think got burnt
out uh i gotta be careful with how i
answer these questions but there were
multiple i really wanted a hundred a
thousand twenty a range between fifteen
and a hundred or they're like between a
hundred and five hundred i have no idea
single digits right yeah yeah kenosha i
i would have to look at the footage
they're about single digits how many
cars were burned out i mean oh man they
were smashing cars on camera they're
just smashing all the windows and
destroying the car that's more than 50
on the first car dealership the car
dealership was smashed out but not
burned out and i mean that this stuff is
so the first one they burnt they burnt
all those cards busted
the same thing happened in ferguson i
went we went and filmed this and it was
crazy it looked like fallout 3. they
went to the dealerships and they poured
there's video of them carrying gas cans
dude when i was in ferguson this was
scary not only were gunshots going off
but there was a point where we were
driving down the road and we saw the
people carrying the gas cans
and we were like
they were yelling and we just like keep
driving keep driving when you got
rioters walking up with gas cans guns we
were like we're not gonna we can't we
can't stop i don't i don't remember if
we got any footage of it we saw when we
were like this is where the danger level
is too high even for us because they
know we're reporters and that's where
bad stuff goes down i got shot at on
more than one occasion now i'm not no
one targeted me no one said hey look at
simple and pull the trigger i was part
of a group of journalists running on the
street gunshots went off on more than
one occasion i had to drop to the ground
and it's not white supremacists doing
this it was black lives matter rioters
who were shooting guns randomly at these
events is it do they not call them
arsonists because they have to be
convicted of arson before you can call
someone an arsonist no no ian they're
peaceful protesters creating harmonious
chaos that of course were speaking
towards the political agenda of the you
know nefarious global elite you know
that night that first night in kenosha
right in front of the courthouse to the
right uh there's a like a dinosaur
museum antifa showed up full black block
and they were getting little black kids
and they were they were like handing
them things in order to burn down
uh the museum and they broke the window
and they were trying to burn down the
building from inside the window this is
what these people do like they
infiltrate some of these movements and
they recruit certain people they'll give
them the shields they'll give them
equipment they'll give them an umbrella
they'll give them something to do in
order to commit some of their mass
violence and a lot of people are like
well is antifa really organized yeah
they are and sometimes they even do like
literally on the job training with
people that are just willing to commit
crimes i want to talk about what this is
really about
the kyle rittenhouse case is about more
than kyle rittenhouse it's about more
than the riots
this may be one of the most
consequential cases of our lifetimes as
the rioters traveled across the country
last year burning down buildings and
smashing windows with a reporting from
michael tracy some of the most important
i've ever seen where he actually went to
these small towns you've never heard of
and saw the damage from the riots
they have defended these rioters they
have protected people like gage
grosskroitz when the when the
prosecution instructed the defend the
detectives not to execute search
warrants take a look at this story from
the daily caller the prosecutor in the
written house trial says you lose the
right to self-defense when you're the
one who brought the gun
a major component of this trial
this is not about kyle rittenhouse in
the bigger picture it is about your
right to keep and bear arms now i will
say
when you look at constitutional carry
gun rights have been winning but this is
a major assault on the culture around it
we can win in the courts we can win in
the legislature but if they can set
precedent that if you bear a gun you are
always the pro provocateur always the
instigator and never intended self
defense that's the argument being played
here if the jury's sides with the
prosecution you will you will start
hearing attempts where they say in the
case of you know the state v written
house the the the jury found that you
know if you're bringing a weapon to a
fist fight you are provoking blah blah i
don't i'm probably getting this a bit
wrong i'm not a lawyer so maybe that
context isn't correct maybe it's
precedent has to be said from a judge or
something there's a question of law the
point is they're trying to make a
cultural moment occur
where kyle reynolds is guilty simply
because he brought a gun now mind you
the question's been answered the judge
this was the most amazing moment i was
screaming i was like yes
the judge
said
to the prosecution
as a question of law because that's what
the judge deals with the the the charge
count six on illegal possession of a
deadly weapon by a person under 18. he
is exempt because he was 17. he looks at
the prosecution and said can you prove
the rifle he he had was under 26 inches
and krause goes it was not under 26
inches and the judge goes count just
count six dismissed
it was not an illegal weapon i think 16
inches is the correct length because if
it's 20.9 26 overall yeah so barrel
length is 16. 26 overall i believe um or
might be 32 i'm not sure
the point is
the judge definitively said
dismissed the law is not that
complicated in my opinion it says
if you are under 18
and in violation of these provisions
which state you're under 16 without a
permit you're under 14 without a
guardian or whatever or you're hunting
without a certificate okay well kyle
right now doesn't is is not violating
any of those statutes 17 year olds are
allowed to bear only rifles and shotguns
kyle right now said he knew he couldn't
have a handgun but i want to get back to
the the main point here that we need we
need to make sure we're paying attention
to if kyle rittenhouse loses
they have that argument they will use it
it will become culture and law is
meaningless in the face of culture
i've pointed it out many times you guys
all understand this there are laws like
you can't put an apple pie on your
window so on tuesday those laws still
exist they're archaic and no one will
ever enforce them why would be absurd
because culturally
we don't do that anymore but the law is
there and they could get you another
problem would a jury really convict you
of an 1800s pie law or something like
that give you a fine i i doubt they
would
but this is what's important if culture
emerges where in the media in our in our
all of our institutions if you have a
gun you are considered an instigator in
any capacity you will never be able to
use a gun to defend yourself they will
always convict you really encourage
people to watch the trial it is a very
it's a blessing that we have this
available just to know to see the
smarminess of this guy and this little
finger i mean he looks like an acts like
little thing it's crazy how much these
like little fingers he does yeah it's
true and and kyle i mean particularly
kyle's testimony
because he's just like uh it was like
his hometown or like his dad lived there
and it was like a city his grandma lives
there his dad lives there he works there
his best friend's there
burnt down it's a carmax
car source
that's terrifying man he's like a young
american who was like i need to defend
my city
it's really crazy how the how ben and
jerry's lied to this this is this is the
funniest thing i tweeted even ice cream
lies and we know ben and jerry's is full
of garbage but they tweeted what what if
a 17 year old you know black person care
a black kid carried a rifle across
illegally across state lines and killed
three white people as if what happened
was a white person carried it up and
across state lines and killed three
black people which it didn't their skin
color did not matter when they were
charging at that guy i don't care if
kyle rittenhouse is white black asian
male female five feet tall six feet tall
well it's funny how they're like this is
really important for self defense as
well jenk yuger was like so how would
the right feel if a black teenager
brought a rifle to a protest and then
shot people and claimed self-defense and
every 2a person was like oh we would
defend him oh for sure yeah you know you
know what i really love
when i was tweeting about 2a and the
absolute rights and people were like i'd
like to see you defend the black
panthers having guns tim and i said
something like abs so effing lutely
every black panther should be armed they
are allowed to walk down those streets
they are allowed to be in this country
going where they pleased with whatever
gun they want and then the socialists
were like based i'm like do you think we
don't want people to have the right to
bear arms and defend them exactly it's
for everybody it's for everybody that's
an american a citizen we have the second
amendment here in the united states
whether left or right and it's like
they've made it like asia it's all
people but what's interesting is how
this has been so spun if if kyle gets
convicted he will be the poster child
for an active shooter and anytime
there's some kind of active shooting
this is not an active shooting situation
but they're going to use it as that so
now moving forward in the united states
of america whenever we do have some kind
of situation like that kyle written
house kyler he will become some kind of
poster child that's going to be used to
attack the second amendment at the same
time but this is what they do
they'll they'll they'll take something
that's a minority
i mean we have active shootings happen
in the united states right but it's not
like this
insane pandemic or crazy thing that's
happening in the united states that's
out of control for the most part people
are responsible gun owners right um but
they do the same thing with covet as
well there's a minority of numbers but
they they blasted across the entire
society where everyone has to be on
lockdown even though there's a minority
of people that could actually die from
they do this with everything they take
the minority and they just spread it
everywhere i want to address that i
don't think first first of all
let me just say i want to say i had
covet and i had it really really bad and
i think the m2 i think the important did
you have it really really bad yeah i
survived i had it like
but i want to say this
i got really sick other people didn't
get really sick some people got sniffles
yeah and so this is why i'm like i
actually think kovit's bad and we want
to take it seriously but we can't do a
one-size-fits-all policy that's my point
but so so ultimate but i don't want to
just get into covet my my main issue
with it is
i don't think it's necessarily that the
media
uh uh and the establishment
i should say the establishment and the
elites do this on purpose but for the
bigger picture in the media the reason
why they highlight every fringe case the
reason why it seems like the apocalypse
is happening with covet is because
the media finds the story and reports it
but they don't report the non-story so
this is what happens with antifa
antifa goes out and they punch someone
in the face is that national news
no of course not this is not
they do it 500 times not a single
instance is national news
they riot across the country some of it
reaches national news because it is
low-level sustained terrorism we don't
hear about it all that much the
mainstream media first of all the
establishment they're biased kamala
harris actively fundraised for these
people so of course there's that and
then there's the media component of
local news outlets for instance that
aren't as you know not always wrapped up
in the manipulation local news do a good
job but they're not going to report on a
guy getting punched
now what happens if one
fringe far right winger gets a gun and
goes and commits an atrocity
international headlines and rightly so i
think rightly so absolutely it's bad
it's abhorrent we got to stop these
people before they can take you know
carry this stuff out it's difficult to
figure out how to do that but everyone
will hear about it and then for those of
us that are in the news and reading the
stories we know that antifa does this
regular people don't because they never
hear it it's not just little crimes i
mean there's people burned alive there's
people shot there was a police officer
trying to stop looting that was
literally shot point blank on on live
streams and it went viral on the
internet but it wasn't really that
prominently talked on the mainstream
media but but i think what's happening
here is that obviously this case is
politically polarized obviously a lot of
ways on this particular case and i think
that's why there's so much attention on
it there's so much hype on it because i
think the establishment wants to use
this case as an example of you can't
defend yourself if you are a gun owner
you have a gun you get attacked
you have to get attacked and and that's
an absurd assertion that they're making
which essentially will leave a lot of
people defenseless and i think that's
why a lot of people who are pro second a
are you know biased in this case and
obviously have something that weighs for
them in this matter for the left a lot
of their agenda weighs on this court
decision so this is going to have huge
ramifications i really want to be
careful with the left and the right
leftists socialist love guns for
everybody two ways for everybody it it
is it is younger populist socialist
lefty types
there are four gun rights it is the
establishment liberal democratic
liberal for the most part
to go to luke's point i think you're
right real quick i'm sorry i'm sorry i
gotta say i gotta say one one real quick
thing on this because i can't let this
one slide the left loves guns until the
leftists love guns until they get the
power then they'll take your guns yes
yeah i i think to go to luke's point is
i think they might even want to do this
to discourage people from even wanting
to buy a gun in the first place oh you
want to buy a gun for self-defense well
look what happened to kyle rittenhouse
if if legal legally
if kyle gets convicted right i'm
speaking hypothetically oh you want to
buy a gun for self-defense well look
what happened to him
if that happens to you you're going to
end up in that position too so i think
that could potentially discourage an
entire generation from even wanting to
own a firearm and literally uphold their
second amendment even without the
verdict look at the way that the
mainstream media responded to this they
called him a white supremacist they
called them an active shooter they
called him guilty uh without even the
trial beginning big tech social media
censored people mainstream media
organizations uh we should corporate
media organization showed up at people's
doors for donating ten dollars to him
people who were in police departments
were fired for donating 25 for him um so
so already we're having him uh kind of
prosecuted in the eyes of big tech
social media the corporate media which
is going to discourage a lot of people
already with this trial that happened
with a lot of people's viewpoints we
have to understand no matter what the
jury decides here there's a bigger
verdict that's going to be kind of
decided by the general public here that
absolutely weighs and i think you could
see that today by some of the judge's
comments he's he he looks like he's
reacting to a lot of the outside
influences here that are trying to push
for a particular outcome for this case
so when this happens i mean this to me
is just like the perfect divide and
conquer agenda i think this is why we're
getting so much play on it because
there's so much weighing on this and i
think a lot of the establishment are
seeing this as an opportunity to ram
through a lot of their absolutely crazy
policies that would disarm people that
would leave them defenseless and at the
end of the day i mean i don't know if
this is the perfect case to make a stand
here but this is a very offensive case
that the establishment is making here
i'm uh i'm actually scared
if kyle rittenhouse does get convicted
this is not the story of an evil
ideologue this is the story
of a 17 year old who said i want to help
everybody this is the story of a 17 year
old who went to kenosha where his father
lives where his grandmother lives where
he works where his best friend lives
where he drives through every day and
said
i will actively help even those who are
rioting who rendered aid two people and
asked if they needed medical assistance
even though he's clearly not with them
as an ideologue or protester kyle
rittenhouse wasn't there for the right
he wasn't there for the left he was just
there to help he didn't want fires he
didn't want destruction and he didn't
want those protesting to get hurt either
so i keep bringing this up because
something stephen crowder talked about
he says this isn't really kyle on trial
here which is great poetry oh great i
gotta adjust my mind turn up a little
bit yeah hold on let me let me just set
this isn't kyle on track hear me how's
that zap yeah this is all of us on trial
yeah it is it's everyone and he's right
because kyle is a normal person who's
just trying to help his community and
people took issue with this being his
community because he didn't live there
he worked there he had family there like
if this isn't your community what is
your community it's not just your
literal neighborhood yes community or
your government address right exactly
kenosha was a crime scene it was a crime
scene it was literally a crime scene and
what people need to understand is
there was a threat to the community i
mean when i came okay the first night i
was there
uh drove back to chicago did a hit with
fox that night and then went all the way
back the third night back to the kenosha
scene
when i got back i was talking to some of
the locals i interviewed them i asked
them are you a black lives matter
supporter this is on twitter dru h live
you can see the interview i asked her
are you a black lives matter supporter
in broad daylight and i was like do you
condone uh the violent writing and she
says yes this is the only way that we
can have our voices heard
you were there the first night and then
this is this is the this is the the day
of the kyle written house shooting i'm
asking these kind of questions with to
these people and this is what they're
saying okay so also i'm walking around
i'm talking to some of the locals i
interviewed the people that had their
businesses burned down to the ground and
they're just confused they're like what
do we have to do with jacob blake right
and i'm walking around the the community
you're seeing boarded up windows they're
riding children live here on them why do
you think they're doing that for for
peaceful protesters you think they're
scared of peaceful protesters no there's
violent criminals that showed up with a
political agenda to burn down a building
that had to burn down a community had
nothing to do with him even right now
tim right now when i was in kenosha i'm
driving down the street i show up i'm
just kind of like having flashbacks i'm
i'm like looking around i'm like this is
crazy surreal to be here again i drive
by a building it's a senior citizen home
the building is boarded up right now wow
and it says right now on the building
the same thing senior citizens live here
even right now they're afraid there's a
threat why why are they afraid right now
why are they because there's a threat
even right now why is the national guard
called out right now because of peaceful
protesters yes because hold on
has anyone reported we expect a guilty
verdict no
across the board from chris hayes to
anna kasparian the narrative has been we
were wrong about cal right now he's
going to be acquitted
now they're preparing for riots how long
can they keep lying to the american
people about what the violence is who
the violence is coming from
well but
why don't we talk about rosenbaum's
criminal record yes so
we got to be very careful in how we
describe this yeah joseph rosenbaum i
will say this right away
i'm sad he lost his life a lot of people
wouldn't say that i don't agree with the
death penalty but he should have stayed
locked up if he stayed locked up for the
atrocities he committed against children
none of this would have happened and i
wish he was still alive for more than
just his own sake but kyle written house
wouldn't be put in this in this position
he wouldn't have to go out and defend
his community from violent rioters he
wouldn't have to worry about injuries
among those violent writers that he was
still trying to help
but i don't believe the death penalty i
don't i i think it's wrong i think you
can't snuff out a life like that and
it's very difficult because i don't know
how we deal with people like rosenbaum
but let me stress
joseph rosenbaum
is an individual who committed
atrocities and i mean that when i say
atrocity because i can't get into
specific details the details of what
rosenbaum did to children are so graphic
and vile that youtube might actually
give me a strike simply for saying it
they will suppress demonetize and
potentially remove because the
description of what rosenbaum was
convicted of is an atrocity against a
child an adult action
forced on children more than one i think
nine i believe right here
oh the exact number tim he wanted
multiples
that
joseph rosenbaum was pushing every
single button to get into some kind of
violent confrontation he was requesting
to be shot joseph rosenbaum right now
shout out to julio rojas if you're
watching julio he reported today he's in
kenosha there are literally protesters
outside with signs with joseph rosenbaum
just as superman as if he's some kind of
fallen hero that is just 100 false aside
from the pedophilic you know practices
he had in his life that night he was
violent there's nothing heroic about
joseph rosenbaum in any way shape or
form i want to be very very careful that
people call me biased okay i i am biased
i have a problem with pedophiles i want
to be very very careful
but i think it's important to point out
what ian just said he was yelling shoot
me over and over again yep this is why
i'm i'm bringing up this charge because
you better believe it when i tweet about
this stuff the left gets really really
mad but this matters now the judge said
he doesn't want the jury to know that
rosenbaum committed atrocities against
several children he was targeting them
he was going after them he went to
prison for it because the jury might say
wow we don't care if it was self-defense
or not at that point i think the judge
made the right call and the jury should
not have heard that but i counter
it was i believe de bruyne or
said joseph rosenbaum yelled i don't
care if i go back to jail
and when that happened the state
objected like whoa whoa whoa the jury
can't know that
no they can and the defense said it's
what he yelled at the moment it's not
it's he's not stating the the criminal
the past of this individual but here's
what i believe
first i will say it again i'm i'm really
really sad
that that this guy lost his life i'm
really sad that he was distraught
distressed and messed up to such an
exciting degree i'm sad that a human
being could become so destructive and be
so evil and wrong
and this person they say was in a mental
hospital or a jail and he should have
stayed there yeah
well i'm sad but i'm sad for the little
kids he raped
but listen i and you're right
rosenbaum shows up on the day he gets
out of jail he's not part of any
movement he's not there in support of
any message that's my opinion
because he hasn't been part of a
movement he's been in prison for what he
did to these children
and he comes out and says shoot me and
he comes out and says i don't care if i
go back to jail those words to me sound
like someone who is depressed distraught
hates themselves potentially suicidal
and for this lashes out with violent
tendencies and projects that under other
people creating the risk against people
like kyle rittenhouse well this is this
is a very very touchy subject i want to
add yeah well yeah we've got to be
careful with our words here but more
importantly you know people with his
charges and he was charged on 11
incidences with five uh kids all boys
aged 9 to 11. that's that's the context
here i'm not going to get into the
specifics here but people who have his
rap sheet do not have a good time in
jail uh they are targets they are
obviously punished by other prisoners
and prisoners of course uh take these
individuals and they do other
unspeakable things to them as their own
form of justice to these types of
specific criminals so for him to say
that he wants to be back in a place
where he's in jail
where he has
not just the prison guards against them
not just the prison staff but the
prisoners against him who are known for
committing atrocities against these
specific types of people
shows you someone that is obviously not
in a right state of mind obviously was
not doing very well and obviously
something that is a very horrible
situation overall i i think that was
relevant to this case because it shows
you that perhaps
what rosenbaum was what motivated him
was
mental illness yes and i don't mean to
disparage people who are who have mental
illnesses i'm saying this man was unwell
to a very extreme degree i think if the
jury understood that it would be a very
very different picture a picture of a
protester who was angry and destructive
or a mentally ill man who had committed
very serious crimes was lashing out and
threatening other people i believe it's
important to stress
i know tucker carlson said it very
bluntly but i'll say it very you know
much more delicately
rosenbaum
had committed violent atrocities against
children he has a tendency towards
violence against other people not just
in this moment telling the jury this man
has a history of violence against others
is extremely important to let them know
it was not a one-off moment where a
protester got mad at somebody they're
arguing provocation that's what the
state said that rittenhouse provoked
rosenbaum by threatening zaminski and
rosenbaum acted in defense of others
they actually argued that if the jury
had known no rosenbaum has been violent
for decades against minors against
children against other people and this
is a part of a pattern of abuse he's
he's he's committed in his life they
might say a mentally ill man and i'm not
trying to disparage the mentally i mean
this is very important someone who needs
to be locked up for their own safety and
the safeties of other safety of others
was just released
attacked somebody and you know what
why would that surprise the state who
released him
they know he's violent they know he's
dangerous and the day he gets out he
attacks another person i think the jury
should have known that
i think that the jury should have been
told he's committed violent
felonies against children
so when you take into consideration why
he attacked
kyle rittenhouse
understand this was not somebody who's
never done it before it's someone was a
pattern of abuse
but they didn't like okay so sorry sorry
sorry i don't understand why they can't
tell you that he has that history of
abuse can you explain that for me there
the concern is
what he did in the past he paid his debt
to society he went to prison he got
released it shouldn't be enough a factor
in whether or not kharnas was defending
himself from him okay but i would argue
first of all i would say that's a good
it's a fair point that i think the judge
for the most part was right in that
regard the judge is trying to make sure
whether it's for conviction or for
acquittal the jury just hears
what happened that night and that's why
he he kicked out a lot of the evidence
from later on because it was prejudicial
and so it's a fair point
but if if if if freddy krueger
goes in and and with his knife hands
slashes up a teenager and then is on
trial and they say don't let anyone know
that he has a history of attacking
children in their dreams in their dreams
which is also real life but my point is
isn't it fair to be like if freddy
krueger attacks a teenage girl and then
she casts a spell and then he turns into
a rat and explodes i'm being very very
well yeah
like if she's he's defeated in the
dreams and they're like well they killed
freddy krueger it's like can the court
please hear about the teenagers whose
dreams he's invaded in the past because
he does this to everyone right it's not
one off it's not one moment rosenbaum
has a violent
abusive history
sorry let me go ahead
just really quick before before i turn
it to you do we know why he was released
was it an effort by some politicians who
wanted to get people out of prison
because there was there was a big effort
underway during that summer where a lot
of hardened criminals were released on
the streets in the name of prison reform
so it'll be interesting to know i don't
know i don't know those details i don't
know those or the lockdowns i don't know
what was happening
but lydia had something and how long had
he been in in jail or in prison before
that day yeah
i don't know tim's looking it up right
now but i was going to say i'm really
glad that the judge said that it needed
to be allowed that he yelled out i'm not
afraid to go back to prison because that
really puts a spotlight on him having
been in prison and literally acting like
he has nothing to lose which i think
really lends to tim's point that he
might have definitely been
just observing the behavior from that
night i could say without a shadow of a
doubt and i have the footage to back it
up as well not just an eyewitness it's
not my opinion
uh joseph rosenbaum was a threat to
those around him to the community to
himself to everybody even to the police
that night okay and you could take a
look at the footage and everything that
i'm saying is 100 true because he was a
threat to every single one of those
people and he to me i think it's just
obvious when you are literally just
so open to say shoot me shoot me n-word
literally trying to get into a
conference a physical confrontation with
somebody with a gun the people at the
gas station i think people just decide
for themselves he chased
someone armed with a rifle
this is all this comes out of testimony
right when he chased him and grew up
on video there not only are there
multiple angles of him doing it oh yeah
the medical examiner said there was
blast burns on his hand because his hand
was on the gun
and
it was on rakita's stream i think
someone mentioned that the moment you
have your hand on someone else's gun
it's now dual possession right so that
means i don't know if that's true
wisconsin maybe it's not because i think
maybe the defense would have argued it
maybe they missed this one
rosenbaum was in possession of a rifle
he also concealed his identity so if you
guys look at my footage and you see when
rosenbaum is in the ultimate gas station
and he's getting crazy with the people
with the rifles saying shoot me inward
shoot me inward
um he's throwing his body on people he's
just getting crazy but then he retreats
to the street and when he retreats to
the street that's when he conceals his
identity with his shirt he takes his
shirt off and then he conceals his
identity and then this is the footage
that i submitted that they played in the
middle of the trial that nobody's ever
seen before is once he retreated to the
street concealed his identity he's
committing arson again he's lighting
another trash can on fire and it's two
minutes i timed it two minutes and five
seconds between he's committing arson
and charging kyle written house from
behind it was it was really amazing how
the the uh we've we've seen leftist
activists lie claiming that kylo renos
was chasing rosenbaum
how the prosecution
tried claiming that he aimed his weapon
at him which is absurd
and then when kyle rittenhouse was
telling his story in his first bit of
testimony and they and they get to that
point where he's he's surrounded
ziminski armed rose and bomb running at
him and he just breaks down
hyperventilating and they all said he's
not crying he's not crying all these
angry anti-written house you know lefty
type people
and when you when you look at the video
which is low resolution and grainy you
can't really see anything on his face
you can see some reflection when you
look at the high res photographs from
court photographer photographers you can
see the tears coming down his face
when i saw that look man
either kyle rittenhouse deserves um
an oscar for that performance or the
reality was the kids he's
it was revealed by the defense he's in
therapy for what he went that was the
moment that he realized he was trapped i
listened to that he said that he
zaminski's in front of him and then to
his right he looks and he sees rosenbaum
running at him he looks to his left and
there's three people and then he stops
and he breaks down he's in he's reliving
that moment when he realized i can't get
away
this is i'm not going to be able to
escape tonight there was people blocking
him everywhere he looked so he ran
towards an opening and that's where the
guy chased him
i i would pose this question and it's
it's speculation pure speculation
how would have this story ended if kyle
didn't fire
same same thing leading up everything's
the same
everything's the same rosenbaum's
violent behavior the whole night
everything's the same leading up to that
moment but kyle didn't fire what would
have happened
well i'll give you my honest opinion
which is pure speculation and random
thought yeah
i don't think rosenbaum would have taken
that weapon and use it on other people
the defense call right now testified
that and i believe it's reasonable to
assume that because he was destructive
he was burning things down
but it's hard for me
because there's that bias on all of us
it can't happen here that idea you know
so when i was reading the story about
ada binger pointing a rifle at the jury
i'm like i'm digging up a story after
story trying to fact check this because
i'm like there's no way
the prosecutor would aim a rifle finger
on the trigger the jury
and the reporting says he did and so i'm
like it's this is why i use newsguard
and people laugh because microsoft
funded and i'm like because it's not
about what i want to believe it's about
what the news reported happened and
maybe they're wrong and maybe they'll
correct and i'll ask you a correction
but that's what happened
when it comes to what happened with the
defense they said rosen uh kyle said he
feared that if he got that weapon he
would use it on kyle and he would use it
on others
i believe there is a strong strong
likelihood
rosenbaum would have used that rifle on
kyle rittenhouse
i don't believe he would have started
using it on others i believe that's
where things get a little exaggerated
however consider
if he so what i mean to say is i don't i
don't think that uh
rosenbaum
was in this frame of mind where he would
take a rifle and just randomly gun
people down that's what they say about
written house like he was a mass shooter
he was gonna an active shooter's gonna
do this however what would have happened
if rosenbaum got the gun and shot kyle
people would have screamed yo he just
shot that dude richie would have run up
run up and rendered hey dakar
rittenhouse people would have started
screaming at rosenbaum rosenbaum would
have started running someone would have
run up and hit him with a skateboard
rosenbaum would start firing on people
so in that regard
the mob would have attacked him not
knowing who he was or carrying who he
was and then he would have used that
rifle on facebook it's definitely the
problem of letting go of your rifle in a
situation like that you can't do it
because of that because of the
possibility that the guy is going to go
go hostile with the weapon but i do know
that zamiski or according to kyle's
testimony told rosenbaum catch catch him
and kill him i don't know if those are
exact words it was grab him catch him
and and kill him
get him get him get him said cranium
that boy cranium that guy people were
screaming all sorts of stuff about about
killing kyle so in his mind you know
best case scenario if he lets go of the
rifle he's going to get shot and killed
you know that that night man
in the in the middle of that riot the
mob mentality for two days straight was
already out of 100. they're burning down
buildings it's out of 100 they're going
they're going they're going
but after kyle shot rosenbaum it went
from like a hundred to a thousand they
they they just were
where is he where is he they even
punched richie right like when richie
was carrying rosenbaum to take him to
the car where they were going to
transport him because they thought it
was richie that shot him they were just
it went from a hundred to a thousand
that's that's the only way i could
describe it it was the mob mentality on
steroids they were looking for him where
is he where is he where is he where they
were seeking to identify him
i can only assume as to why i don't
think they wanted to have a conversation
with him and let's not let's not forget
there were many other incidences across
this country where right wingers were
shot by leftist activists some more
assassinated some were
shot during altercations but these
incidences happened with the same exact
almost situation but different political
ideologies at the at different ends of
them so to have one of these highlighted
and the other ones ignored literally
brings up the larger question of what's
really going on here with the spin the
play the attention that all of this
getting i think it's deliberate and i
think there's a big big big agenda
behind all of this
they don't they don't they don't want us
to have guns man you know the most
annoying thing to me is when i see these
memes from establishment democrat type
saying like no one's trying to ban your
guns and i'm like
first of all in west virginia for the
most part there's a lot of guns that are
not banned i'm allowed to have but you
can't bring them to virginia you can't
bring them to maryland you can't bring
them to new jersey it's scary in new
jersey i went to a gun store and they
had a a a a
a certain weapon as an other firearm and
i'll just leave it next i want to get
into too much details about the weapons
i own and when i was buying it i was
like oh i really want to buy that's a
great weapon and the guy said you're
going to need this certificate proving
it's legal and i was like what why is it
carry it with you at all times if you
ever have this in your possession and i
was like what why
because based on how it looks it's
illegal it is banned in new jersey and
i'm like it's just a nine it was it's a
nine millimeter rifle basically that's
what it was and i was like what that
that's banned
well no
but a cop wouldn't understand that he'd
probably arrest you for it and i was
like dude this is crazy you know what
you said what did you say earlier it's
not so much
uh
leftists that don't like guns what did
you say like neo establishment
neo-liberal types liberals the
neo-socialists youth love guns okay
until they gain power but i want to i
want to encourage them because they seem
so afraid of firearms and so afraid of
guns whether it's a handgun or a rifle
shotgun whatever right they're they're
so afraid
i want to encourage you guys that are
listening go to a gun range
you will see it is probably one of those
safest places in your community for two
reasons if anything goes down at a gun
range you're gonna be safe but number
two
the practices at a gun range are at
least all the ones i've ever been to are
super safe people are constantly
checking checking checking checking
everyone's watching each other's backs
everyone is fully aware of what's
happening with each other is this loaded
is that it
and i think a lot of people haven't
experienced that so they think it's just
like so it's like like the bat cave and
there's all these guns come out and
everyone's irresponsible just want to
kill people you know i would encourage
people to check that out you're right
but i understand why they feel that way
when you watch the prosecutor in a case
involving possession of a gun
pointing the rifle at the jury with his
finger on the trigger the state
prosecutor would be kicked out of a gun
range if he did that yes he would be not
allowed he would be banned for life yeah
absolutely i mean this is just
absolutely insane incredulous behavior
that deserves to be called out i'm
surprised no one's really talking about
this
little finger on the trigger
i want to shout out chapter saying
little binger by the way
if
if 88
outside
in west virginia
and he was walking down the street
and he went up to somebody in full view
of a huge crowd of people and said have
you checked that is it unloaded grabbed
it and pointed at the crowd someone
would shoot him
not guaranteed i don't wanna i'm gonna
be over hyperbolic but some people would
probably raise their guns like drop it
drop it now
aiming a rifle at a crowd of people
someone would tackle him if he was if he
was in a protest the cops would throw
him to the ground and arrest him on the
spot and he did it in a courtroom in a
jury and and this is what people see and
you know what cassandra fairbanks we did
something funny she's like maybe
liberals shouldn't be allowed to have
guns and i'm like i get it but that's
the liberal
establishment argument people shouldn't
be allowed to have guns because some
people are as stupid as ada binger
irresponsible man he did exactly what
what alec baldwin did
he took the gun
it wasn't loaded and he pointed it and i
don't know if he pulled the trigger but
he put it he put his finger on it which
is essentially pulling it
i mean it's not pulling it but it is we
we have uh safety purposes we are
chilling in our mobile studio great it's
amazing it's i this is so cool actually
i like it better than a regular studio
yeah so this is like you're gonna have
to like brand this tim like you know how
like you have like certain packages
where people want to be like music
artists oh get this package you could
get a guitar you could podcast 100 with
the microphone you know you don't never
know the future man right
there i've been doing this for a year
and a half all my videos are in my rv i
love rv live with bite inflation going
on in about a year people are gonna be
making a million bucks a year so a
hundred thousand i'm kidding i'm kidding
no no but i was bringing this up because
in our regular studio we have replica
firearms
and secured we have real firearms i have
a safe and so
first whenever someone comes over if
we're ever going to do anything i i will
always make sure someone handles the
replica or effectively inactive on
incapable of firing weapon to see how
they behave first you will never be
allowed to touch anything i own
unless you can display proper gun
etiquette and that being said too for
the most part in the studio no one ever
touches anything any of my weapons but
when it comes to going to the range in
west virginia where you know you can you
know uh people can use weapons and when
you're out hunting and stuff like that
we always i always i'm very very careful
i have guns i have legal weapons and i
have them because we live in the middle
of nowhere but when someone comes over
i'll give them a replica and see what
they do with it and i tell you this
people have no idea what they're doing
and i'll say something like this hey
this this can't fire but still never
point it at someone and they go okay and
they drop it down i'm like give it back
you can't touch never again right this
is why i don't let people touch my
actual weapons in a home setting if we
go to a range and we're in a proper
controlled environment okay
show me that you know how to do it and
we can you can here use my weapon
there's the target stuff like that but
in my house i am not going to take that
risk because
seven out of ten people
they have no idea but when we get like
military people
you know they'll take the replica
they'll hold it up they'll look at it
inspect it and they'll be this is great
and they'll never point it they'll keep
it down it'll keep it up depending on
what floor we're on and i'm like see
these guys know what they're doing i'm
not going to take the average person has
no idea what they're doing to a range
where they're going to be like standing
there with the gun and then turn around
and be like hey the instructor is going
to grab him and pin him to the ground
you get slapped for that at least
minimally yeah but it's a big
responsibility and i think this is why
there's been such a coordinated attack
against gun owners because they're some
of the most responsible human beings on
the face of the earth especially
concealed carry
members permit members if you look at
the crime statistics of of people who
have those specific licenses they are
astronomically way lower than the
general public you look at the people
that do commit the gun gun crime are the
people who get guns illegally in major
urban areas predominantly but but there
is this element you have this firearm
you have a huge huge responsibility you
better take it seriously you better
practice with it you better learn how to
clean your firearm this is life and
death i think many people understand
that and i think this is why there's
been such an attack against this culture
where even you know if you show photos
of of instagram
on instagram of you holding a firearm or
facebook automatically gets down ranked
automatically there's a big
stigma against you there shouldn't be
there should be oh this guy's a
responsible human being just like you
have a fire extinguisher in your house
you should have a firearm uh based on
different scenarios and situations that
you're in especially if you're on a farm
so that's just basic common knowledge
that should be you know more available
to everyone but the culture hasn't
spread as far yeah
the majority it's sad that the majority
of those responsible get punished for
the minority that aren't so i'm i'm
actually really optimistic about this
particularly egregious display from ada
binger because to me this is such an
obvious clear indicator that the people
who want to ban your right to bear any
kind of weapons have no flaming clue
what they're talking about they don't
know what they're doing they don't know
what kind of gun they're talking about
they're literally holding it with their
finger on the trigger even i know that
and i haven't been around guns all that
much it's beyond that they're literally
arguing it's wrong for people to point
weapons at other people and then he
points the weapon out of their people
like with the finger on the trigger like
yo hey guess what all the two-way people
agree it's wrong to point your weapon
you know negligently at other people
just like that everyone agrees like that
alec baldwin well the funny thing is
with alec baldwin the left is defending
him saying it's not his fault and i'm
like but he was holding the weapon he
pulled the hammer back and pulled the
trigger
when when the prosecutor said
you are responsible for every bullet
that comes out of your gun i said he is
100 correct yep alec baldwin let me tell
you guys something the the detectives in
the rittenhouse case testified they were
asked
did you file uh when did you start your
investigation they say we started the
investigation here and you filed charges
against cal rittenhouse the prosecutor
did before the investigation concluded
and they say that's actually fairly
normal it's a known homicide it's a high
profile case and you know we know what
happened that night so we file the
charges for the for you know for the
crime and then we'll begin investigating
and pulling the facts together and i
said oh it's not uncommon to do that oh
oh because we know that an individual
was involved in a homicide oh so is alec
baldwin gonna get arrested any time soon
i know it's a different state but if you
want to argue it's not uncommon to file
charges against someone and then
investigate alec baldwin shot a guy i
mean shot a lady and a guy yeah okay
well then file the charges against him
and then work your investigation no
now i'm not gonna i don't want to rehash
the alex baldwin stuff completely but
i'll just point out they're very
different cases
but if you believe
if we know for a fact someone pointed a
gun and pulled the trigger and killed
someone else we can file charges before
the investigation then alec baldwin
should be should have been charged and
should be awaiting trial the same as
writtenhouse did yes it's a different
case i know it's different charges i
know i'm just saying if we know he he
pulled the gun and pulled the trigger
then why aren't they filing charges
against them they know he did it now
they can figure out if there's
mitigating factors for kyle rittenhouse
he says i have an affirmative defense i
was acting in self-defense they said oh
yeah prove it to a jury okay alec
baldwin he says it was an accident i was
told it wasn't loaded okay alec tell it
to a jury the jury will decide they're
doing it to written out but not alec
baldwin spare me dude well alec baldwin
hates trump so he's a celebrity yeah
yeah
that's how the media plays their dirty
games probably it probably really is as
simple as that yeah it's getting really
crazy out there you know
it's it's
the political establishment realized the
power of the media a long long long time
ago a long time ago
and they've been gaining power and it's
been encroaching and they use this in
key areas
and it is remarkable that you have
conservatives have completely overlooked
these district attorney political races
i'm not sure who tweeted it so forgive
me for for not crediting you on this
tweet they said people concer i think
was michael malus maybe he said
conservatives need to realize that
prosecutors are politicians with the
same motivation as any other politician
and will act accordingly amen
let's go to super chats if you haven't
already smash that like button subscribe
to this channel we're gonna have a
members only uh segment of the show
coming up around 11 or so p.m eastern
time but let's read what y'all have to
say and make sure you once again smash
that like button
we have a lot of super chats a lot of
comments
all right let's see there's a lot of uh
first of all artemis fowl hasn't has a
super chat we can't read
comparable to what tucker carlson said
but mostly because it's a
family-friendly show and you know
all right let's see bradley says there a
cgi image of who he's pointing the gun
at no there isn't this is amazing the
computer generated image i believe it
took a few hours to produce
the computer tried to speculate it was
an algorithm trying to generate what the
image might look like should not be
admitted evidence but the best part was
the defense was like who is he pointing
the gun in the prosecution says the
minsky's the defense says the zaminski's
aren't in the photo
yet still it gets admitted into evidence
that to me is insane
if there's cgi of who bangers pointing
the the gun at because that's a that's a
meme oh a lot of potential memes come
out oh they are i get it again a lot of
memes they're looking at that we're
talking about can we we should we should
get a uh uh yeah so bangers pointing the
rifle why don't we do a cgi of being a
mock-up yeah and then we can see because
if kyle you know here's another this is
a really important point
when they're saying he pointed at the
banger point of the rifle at the jury
i'm biased even though i don't like
bingo i'm like i can't imagine him being
that dumb to do it
and the jury's cropped out of the image
but you know what if bingo wants to
argue that the ziminskis who are cropped
out of the image had a gun pointed at
them and it's blurry and grainy
then okay bingo we'll play it your way
you pointed the gun at the jury as far
as i'm concerned yeah right
all right let's see
enigma says hey tim did you catch the
prosecution rebuttal it was a mess
basically a tantrum for the prosecution
who are mad for getting called out they
even tried to say there is no such thing
as a left-handed gun i saw that
you know what's crazy that the judge had
to dismiss the jury i think twice yeah
during their final during the rebuttal
so closing
well so here's what happens the
prosecution is their closing argument
the defenses are closing argument and
then the prosecution prosecution gets a
rebuttal
i actually really like that system i'll
tell you why the prosecution goes in
blind they don't know what the defense
is going to say they make their argument
the defense then gets to base their
closing argument
to discredit the prosecution so we give
the prosecution like a half an hour or
so to address some of the arguments
the state gets the last word hmm i'm not
a big fan
but during their rebuttal in their last
statement the judge had to dismiss the
jury because they were saying factually
as matters of law inaccurate things the
most important of which is the state
controls the right to remain silent
if
because they're prosecuting ziminski the
defense cannot call him as a witness
because zaminski will say i plead the
fifth
the state can call him as a witness and
grant him immunity thus getting the
testimony if it favors them which means
ziminski's testimony likely did not
favor the prosecution because if it did
they would have granted him immunity to
get kyle convicted the defense doesn't
have the ability to do that
they lied and claimed but they can just
plead the fifth the defense said i want
a sir rebuttal to tell the jury the
state controls zaminski's right to
remain silent so we didn't have the
opportunity and the judge said no tell
me the judge's bias for the defense the
judge said no i don't think i'll do that
and i'm like that's bs
the state can grant immunity and get the
testimony if it proved right now it's
guilty and they didn't because it
doesn't i guess well you got to remember
that kyle is innocent until he's proven
guilty beyond a reasonable doubt and
that's the that's the weight on the
prosecution they have a big job
if they want to try and prove that with
blurry footage and and weird testimony
yeah
dan daniel maxwell says one common trait
of all authoritarian groups is they all
believe the common people are unable to
think for themselves
and so this is where it's interesting my
personal opinion
is that in many instances the defense
didn't object to what the prosecution
was saying because i got to tell you
i was getting annoyed by the prosecution
a lot i think a lot of people were he
was really condescending in that video
you played earlier it's it's not just
directly and it's not just that
it's it's like
there's condescending in a negative way
and there's condescending in a
patronizing way yeah
kyle
but didn't you want
to kill those people and i'm like oh
shut up just be straight tell me what
happened
kyle
your gun
kills people it's like you remember when
aoc was testifying before homan who was
the that was he that advice yeah i think
and she goes with all due respect
legal asylees have broken no law and i'm
like shut up man
you know but look that works on people
and then and then homan goes they did
violate section three c9a illegal and i
was like oh wow i don't know the actual
alarm he's giving you numbers but
that is grading to me as an adult
i imagine that jury's like we don't want
to be here
you know we're told we have to be here
we're here in a jury we'll do our duty
don't waste our time seriously hey some
people might be swayed by it i think
i think you could tell the judge was
getting irritated with him too and the
jury's watching that as well you know
and i think when you're an environment
like that i think he did a pretty good
job irritating everybody in the room and
if that was his intention
maybe he thinks that's a good strategy
to win the jury over
i don't know i think we're just going to
find out but drew can i ask you i don't
know if we're uh going off on a tangent
a little bit looking at the jury where
do you think they're stand what do you
think their decision will be
i don't want to comment on that got it
um i just will say that being in the
room it was very tense
and i know that having a direct
conversation with him
i could pretty much sense he was trying
to stray away from my testimony so that
they obviously couldn't hear it i'm not
accusing him of that it just seemed that
way because every time he would
tell me something it was to divert from
the actual testimony i was there to give
and first he assassinated my credibility
then my character and it led to him and
i just kind of going back and forth
where you know i had to define the word
apparently for him and he just was crazy
like he he was because that but that's
what he was trying to do to me he was he
was digging digging digging he was like
you tweeted this on twitter on
can you be more specific because i tweet
a lot i'm a public figure he's like this
tweet here you said this you inserted
your opinion just like tim is
impersonating him you inserted your
opinion here i was like no i said
apparently he's like what difference
does that make
it's not my 100 opinion or 100 of this
happen this is kind of as far as i can
see so you jumped to an apparent
conclusion it's kind of what it
apparently means it's
someone updated us on what rocato was
saying uh desmond sullivan says when
rakeda said hernandez was a bad witness
that was a criticism of the media for
creating pre-trial bias some jurors want
to disregard evidence
so i don't think it was about you yeah i
i think you said a lot of really really
important things and the funny thing is
about how they accuse you of bias it's
very simple i don't care let's see let's
ask the public if you guys thought live
in the chat i was a great witness drop a
one in the comment section right now i
think everybody's a big fan of being
honest and then drop two if you thought
it was just trash
i said it very simply if well look if i
was on the jury i would get really
offended by the point of bias because
i'd be like is he lying or not okay are
you going to get him for perjury or not
if he's telling the truth and he's
telling me what he saw i don't care what
you think his politics are yeah just
evidence speaks for itself the same as
this is the footage the same is true for
gage grosskroyd's it's all ones
everyone's spamming all ones like a
couple
two haters
okay when gage grosskroyd's testified
i'm like i want to hear what he has to
say i'm not going to call him a liar and
then he lied definitively and easily
lied and they're like you lied to the
police and he's like oh no no i didn't
they're like you said this yeah
he lied i i gotta tell you man when when
the prosecutor said
mr grosskroitz at this point in your
confrontation with mr renounce you had
drawn your gun and there's a video of it
playing and gage goes
no
and then he's like here's the video
we're playing right now and you have a
gun in your hand and he goes
yes i couldn't believe when i said
are you kidding me now that was a lie
he lied out right
now you gave video yeah if they want to
get you for perjury because he thinks
you're biased and lying you need to only
go to the video and be like hey the
video shows something different i could
have sat there and pushed play and just
narrated it mm-hmm yep and that's that's
that's really true that's the reality
yeah you're supposed to you're supposed
to say i don't remember like he could
have said i don't remember not not
directly no i would imagine if he truly
didn't remember we got a good one here
this is important stunning and brave
says the mccloskeys went down for doing
the same thing ada binger did
let me remind you that the mccloskey
wife
said that the gun she had was checked
and the firing pin was reversed and it
was incapable of firing
and they got charged over that ada
binger says but i asked if it was
unloaded before i pointed the weapon and
put my finger on the trigger ridiculous
doesn't matter yo man never assume
if i was assumed if i was in a courtroom
in any capacity i don't care if i was
there as a reporter and he raised that
weapon and did that i would have yelled
hit the deck i would have i i'm not i'm
not joking
i don't care if i'm a juror or i would
have if i was uh if i was like they're
spectating and he did that i would have
gotten up and be like you're out get
stop him yeah nobody did
nobody did that was shocking to me and i
guess probably the defense were like
that was really good for us huh like
that was an insane thing to do
yo man
you guys you've seen the videos there's
a guy at a gun range with his buddy and
he's like aiming the weapon and then he
turns to his friend and the instructor
runs up grabs him and puts him in like
an arm lock and drops him and then drags
him out and they're like whoa
there's the video of will smith the
guy's picking up the gun and will smith
looks at him and smacks the gun down
you don't see like if will smith
is gonna smack a gun from like smack
their hand down when they draw a gun
nobody in the court could have seen
bingo do this and been like grab him
[Music]
and you know what
i i'd imagine no bailiff no judge would
would react negatively towards you i'd
actually think they'd be like
actually you're right he should have
done that
i don't care if someone says it's clear
alec baldwin was told his gun was clear
too yeah you never assume never assume
kids you never assume you assume that
it's not safe so you're constantly
checking to make sure that it's safe
always with guns let's read this one we
got uh
strider and coda says hernandez when
binge brought up your tweets why didn't
you say the one about rosenbaum being a
child abuser we'll put it that way it
would have been epic um the reason why
was because i was aware
of that rule
that it can't be brought in and i wasn't
sure
if i quoted my own tweet
that that would somehow mistrial i don't
know you know so i just played it safe
i'm not trying to hide anything um
that's why i didn't quote the tweet
because i didn't want to
do some kind of damage that i
unintentionally would have done by just
quoting did they instruct you on what
you could or couldn't say nobody
instructed me that's interesting because
i i
there was accusations that the
prosecution wanted to trigger a mistrial
so they get a do-over
and
by bringing up your tweets they open the
door to anything you've ever tweeted
about so that's why they said like you
could have said i also tweeted a lot of
things about the character of these
individuals and who they were and they
weren't opinions such as
and if you did bring that up the judge
might have been like miss trial
that's why i didn't do it i wasn't sure
well i you know it's it's hard to say
what you were supposed to do but i'll
put it this way i think the only thing
that matters is that you just answered
the questions as they were asked you
didn't
outside of like when he said the things
in kanoa you said violent riots you
didn't say and also by the way so and so
did x i actually think that was the
right thing to do you said that they
didn't tell you uh what was often on
limits but that you nobody coached me
you knew ahead of time that it was you
weren't supposed to talk about
rosenbaum's
that's been reported multiple times so
you knew through the media before you
went in yeah i've heard that
i wonder if that's like test witness
testimony tampering just well you can't
avoid it with modern media you know look
when um de bruyne said rosenbaum yelled
i don't care if i go back to jail they
objected and the judge was like
the witness said he heard it it's part
of it it's in
and so there's something i'm not a
lawyer again but we've all heard opening
the door the prosecution made arguments
about opening the door to evidence
he i think he may have potentially
opened the door to anything you've ever
tweeted about
but the defense probably couldn't ask
you about it but i think maybe if you
said it then he'd be like your honor
that's not supposed to come up and he'd
be like you asked him about his social
media posts
you know i don't know what the outcome
would have been that's why i played safe
yeah no i think it's not even about that
i think the fact that you simply just
answer the questions that you were asked
yeah you know it's it you weren't
injecting your your bias if you were
biased the way they claimed you probably
would have been like hey did you guys
know that this dude was you know
committing atrocities against children
and and that's the thing too is towards
the end of my testimony you could
clearly see that
binger was and i know lawyers do this
they ask the same question 30 times
because they want to get an answer out
of you that they didn't get the first 29
times and hopefully maybe on the 30th
time you'll give them the answer that
they wanted because he's getting annoyed
right um i saw him pull that on me
because at the end he was like so you
feared for your life because someone was
pointing a gun at you with a laser and i
was like i'm always fearing for my life
in the midst of riots
you
were fearing for your life because i was
like these are stupid
i didn't want to be misidentified as a
writer i said it like two times and he's
like are you just incapable of answering
the question and then the judge was just
like where's where's this going yeah
he's like he answered the question the
jury was watching all that i'll just
right and they watched a lot of they
watched all that
all right ready to rumble says msnbc
didn't show the defense's closing
arguments but they showed both of the
prosecutions
no wonder why the left is clueless
because they're lacking real information
you know what said nbc news reported gun
charge dismissed and all the responses
were like the judge's bias just as white
supremacists they're like the law
clearly states he can't have a gun how
is he getting away with this and it's
like just watch the trial just read the
law take two seconds to do a google
search they don't want to well they were
going after the judge because of that
comment he made about the asian food
right awesome
dude he's talking about that's not that
listen i'll just say this in the
courtroom
he it's so tense in there
he's he's he's saying things like that
because he's just trying to
disperse the tension everyone's just on
edge i mean you got the because it's
it's really weird and awkward because
everyone's arguing right on tv the
defense the prosecution and then you
know the the feed cuts let's go to lunch
they're all together right they're
having to talk to interact with each
other we're all gonna go eat da da so it
the judge is trying to just like really
just make it less tense in the room and
it's just to me this is why i i i hate
the
the corporate media when they do stuff
because they take something like that
and they try and make it more divisive
when it's someone actually just trying
to bring peace to a situation right
here's billy bob super chat he says your
drawing rings true spooky
so um on our last episode
i claimed that i had a picture
of kyle rittenhouse pointing his weapon
at protesters
and the picture was a crude stick figure
drawing i had made in about 10 seconds
to make a point
that you were right
but hold on hold on i think you're
attacking the traveler on the other side
of the paper i had another crude drawing
where i said ladies and gentlemen this
is a picture of ada binger pointing his
rifle and i didn't say the jury though
it was kyle i said kyle
i think richie mcginnis was behind him
in the picture no no in this one it was
just kyle it was it was a squiggly angry
face and then a stick figure pointed
weapon and i said this is this is i said
i have a picture of ada bingo pointing a
gun kyle rittenhouse and the the joke
was when he claimed his cgi image was a
picture of something and it's just a
rendering from it from a computer from a
week ago or whatever i'm like okay well
i've got a picture too and then ian's
like the pictures are drawing and i'm
like we know what's the type of picture
but it is out you know what that really
reminded me of um and and i was looking
at this after my testimony so it's
completely irrelevant but you know those
pictures
where you show it to like five different
people
and they all see five different things
yeah but it's like the same picture
rorschach test dude that's exactly what
that like at least for me personally i
stared at it for like
15 minutes i'm like okay maybe i could
see what they're saying i'm like let me
come back to this i come back to them
like
i see something completely different
like it's just not to me personally i
don't think that is we needed to do a
skit on this it would be a great skit
where there's like a doctor and he's
like tell me what do you see and it's
like
it's an ink blot and it's like i see a
butterfly and he goes to the next one
and it's like a giraffe and he goes to
the net what next one and it's the blown
up and major cut right now i see
kyle rittenhouse pointing a rifle and
it's like a banger he's like pointing a
rifle and a bunch of protesters after
switching his right-handed rifle to his
left hand putting the chamber near his
face that would eject the casing into
his face it's like
interesting he's writing stuff down
that's what you see that's what you see
that would have been really funny all
right we got one from tommy what's he a
gross grossing he says the duty to
retreat stuff became their swan song
after ada started pitching the
provocation angle if someone provokes a
fight they have a duty to retreat before
having the privilege of self-defense
okay so that that that makes sense so
even if this is interesting
i do remember when the judge was
instructing on this and i felt like this
is it right now swins because the
argument is if you provoke someone
and then you try to retreat
then you can defend yourself if you
provoke a fight
you can't defend yourself because you
started it if you provoke a fight and
run away you can defend yourself so
that's why they were like you had a duty
to retreat and then i'm kind of like
is it isn't that a video of kyle
rodriguez running away that's him
even if he did provoke it he ran away
after the fact the funny thing is the
argument for the prosecution was that
rittenhouse was trying to lead rosenbaum
to an empty parking lot like for what
this is the craziest circuitous plan
i've ever heard from someone conspiracy
theory i just think it's crazy how the
media tries to spin it as like an active
shooting situation because
for me after kyle
you know came back around the car he
shot rosenbaum you know comes around the
car he checks him he pulls out his phone
and he's making a phone call that's when
you see in my footage he jogs right past
me
and
an active shooter is isn't just
kind of like walking past people that
are you know running towards one of the
people that they just shot and that
happened multiple times like so even for
me
i walk right past him and he just went
right past me because he was already
gonna go turn himself into the police
yeah and then they started trying to
identify where he is where is he at
where's he at i'm telling you man he
went from like a hundred to a thousand
uh i got a super chat here that's
triggering i'm very triggered i'm very
angry
james fisher says tim i'm always a day
behind because i listen to you on
spotify please stop referring to an ar
as an assault rifle there is no such
thing that's just causing fear around
these weapons ar stands for armor light
rifle cheers brother great show i am
triggered by this because i have never
referred to an ar15 as an assault rifle
an m16 correct if i'm wrong luke is an
assault rifle a select fire rifle now
there are a lot of people who say
assault rifle doesn't exist select fire
rifles are called select fire rifles if
you pull up
the colloquial breakdown
most people will define assault rifle as
i think it actually came from nazi
germany where the term comes from it
refer refers to select fire so it's bur
it's full auto burst and
and uh semi-automatic one paul one you
know i've never said ar stands for
assault rifle i know what an arma light
rifle is there are a bunch of different
kinds
do you think you think that armalite
should change the name of their company
no change their but i don't think
is armalite even a company isn't it
still a company i don't think so it was
back in the day armalite made a bunch of
different kinds of weapons is there like
an ar-12 and you know things like that
i'm not the biggest gun person but i
certainly never called an armalite rifle
an assault rifle i've made references to
legitimate assault rifles by saying not
a single person in kenosha was armed
with an assault rifle it was founded in
the 50s armalite in inc and then ended
in the in the 80s
i am not the biggest gun expert in the
world but i've at least done the google
search we live in this weird what do you
call a simulacrum where i think if they
did change the name of the weapons to
like a zr like a 120 or something they'd
stop thinking they were assault rifles
they'd stop arguing it that like here's
the funny thing
when they're like no one should have an
ar-15 and it's just like you know how
many guns there are that aren't ar-15 or
ar15 style that are semi-automatic
rifles with magazines and function are
functional identical it's the weirdest
thing they know so little about it
there's tons of weapons where you put an
interchangeable magazine with a with a
drum or you know whatever and it's
semi-automatic during the jury selection
didn't one woman they asked her like do
you have an issue with an ar-15 or a gun
like this and she was like i don't think
anyone should own a machine gun yeah oh
that's right they released her and
yeah and here's the best part there was
a guy who was like i don't think i would
be a fair juror because i believe in the
right to bear arms and it's like
that doesn't make you an unfair juror
the constitution says you get to do this
and you judge people as a as a peer
accordingly
i swear conservatives man
what if you're just trying to get out of
jury duty that's true that's true that's
very impossible possibly
all right let's see sfc retired says the
ar platform is ambidextrous it has a
brass deflector for left-handed shooters
i understand that that that's that's an
important point too and other people
have mentioned that you can put a a
deflector as well if you don't have one
but my point is i just did a google
search
first of all i know i have um i can't
remember the name i have a nine
millimeter macro of handgun from like
the 60s a cold war weapon it's polish
and it is only right-handed the way that
the the the the grip is shaped you put
in your left hand and it like pushes
into your palm and it's really difficult
to hold and i gotta be honest the soviet
weapons they don't feel good to fire it
hurts it like it bites you know it's not
fun and whenever we go to the range
everyone's like i'm not gonna use that
one and i'm like but it's it's makarov
it's you know was it nine by eighteen i
think yeah so it's like it's like it's
it's it's a unique soviet nobody wants
to do it anyway i digress it's a
right-handed weapon and so i did a
simple google search to look and there's
they have designed left-handed weapons
where it ejects the other side and i
even watched a video of a guy who had
right eye damage so he but he was
right-handed so he has a special gun
that uses his left eye yeah and it loops
around in the other direction it's it's
interesting i think it's a p64
yeah p64 is that what it's called
yeah i have two of them actually
yeah they're not fun to fire they're not
fun both right-handed are they all right
they're all right-handed i'm pretty sure
they were like designed that way
and the funny thing is i'm like this is
such a soviet weapon it works it hurts
but i'm sure the soviets didn't care do
i care about your personal comfort no
here's a gun
like i guess you know i don't know if
this is true but my understanding is
that they mass produced in world war ii
really really awful garbage tanks
but a lot of them i've heard that too
and they were like they would be easily
taken out but there was just too many
and so they just over numbers that's
right
again approach yeah i mean that sounds
like the soviet strategy
all right let's see bc says did anybody
see the footage showing that rittenhouse
did not point the weapon on gab quote
new fbi infrared video blows cal right
now's prosecutor's case into a million
pieces i watched a lot of that footage
and people did like graphic overlays and
they broke down they did like outlines
and i gotta admit those videos are very
accurate i wonder if the defense is
using social media decentralization as a
tool in this because they should have
that'd be smart yeah so in this video at
least one of my watched you can clearly
see this blurry figure but you can see
the way he's moving when he runs and you
can tell he's facing forward they then
say if he is facing forward they draw an
outline around how he's holding his
weapon and at no point did he ever point
it at anybody what they're trying to
argue is that his arm being up when he
was when he was when he was holding
pointing the gun down which is act you
know muscle control they were trying to
argue that the gun going up because it
was a thin
pixel line was actually him left-handed
like this
pointing the weapon at other people
instead of pointing it down and because
kyle testified oh i'm pointing my gun
down i think right yeah yep and i love
it when the prosecution was like here
you are
pointing your weapon
at gage gross grace whose hands are up
and then kyle goes
this is actually just a freeze frame if
you play the video i'm actually lowering
my weapon
they pause the video while he's lowering
his weapon and say look you're pointing
it at him it's like play the video and
he's going like he's pointing it down
i gotta say too desperate when they
played the video in slow motion
after rittenhouse you know is rolling on
the ground in turns towards gage
grosskroyd's i was surprised
at the defense the discipline
i i'll say it always like i wish it
didn't happen
i don't think kyle should have been
there for a variety of reasons i know
there's a lot of people think he should
have been there i just i don't think any
of them should have been there is the
point not just kyle but
kyle rolls on the ground and as he's
rolling immediately
aims perfectly towards the guy with the
glock pointed at him
and then lowers his weapon almost
immediately disabled the arm that was
holding the weapon it's crazy right he's
extremely accurate like he did a one
shot one shot on the one shot of course
cut uh with rosamond fired four shots
all into the body and point seven
seconds amazing wow really impressive
that's like a fight for your life well
it's it it's i i i i struggle to be
positive in this regards like impressive
in the sense that he restrained himself
to a result a resounding degree
and it must be stated and the defense
mentioned this but should have drilled
it home
after he fires on gross croix and gross
kreutz runs away
multiple gunshots are fired and
rittenhouse calmly lowers his weapon
turns around and starts walking he
doesn't return fire there's a guy with a
weapon standing right next to him he
doesn't run out of he doesn't attack him
he immediately goes back to getting to
the police with his hands up right he's
pepper sprayed i don't know if he was
actually illegally has been acknowledged
he was concussed but it sounds like he
took some head trauma on the run and
then he passed out according to his
testimony passed out on the way and
that's when they hit him with the
skateboard for the second time is it
it's confirmed that it was the guy's
right hand right arm right gross course
had the pistol on his right arm yeah
what what we we talked about on friday
but i think if you miss it you got to
hear it the prosecution was like
but mr riddenhaus
gage grosskroitz had a gun
he could have shot you from 40 or 50
feet away so
he wasn't a threat to you and kyle was
like he had a gun pointed at my head
if it were me i'd say
for those that don't understand handguns
like yourself mr binger
someone like gage grosskroyce who
probably doesn't have extensive firearms
training i can't make that assumption
but in the heat of the moment while
running the likelihood that somebody is
going to actually make contact with a
handgun is very very low so the fact is
that because he was running at me with
the weapon i understand handguns have
been to the range and know how they work
my assumption was he knew he couldn't
make the shot unless he got point blank
so as soon as he ran up to me
that was actually the bigger threat in
fact i would say this
when he was at 40 or 50 feet you're
right he could have shot me and the
reason i didn't fire on him is because i
knew he would have missed but once he
closed that distance and pointed the gun
on my head from about three feet away
that's when he wasn't gonna miss and i
had no choice but to fire to defend
myself and stop that threat
the defense didn't bring that up
hindsight is 20 20 and it's really easy
for me to be some like armchair
spectator with popcorn going like
i know better than the lawyers but i
think i think that would have been a
very powerful statement like
you're right he could have shot me from
40 feet away anyone missed but i didn't
shoot him because i thought he would
miss and he wasn't a threat until he got
he closed that distance and i had no
choice
let's do a couple more here we'll do a
couple more we got a lot of people here
we go
home b says the kenosha police
department must suck if it takes a 17
year old kid to go into a situation with
an ar and a fanny pack and a med kit to
stop fires and pretend to be an emt
why wart the police out there like i
know they were further away and they and
this is a tactic they use but the police
look they're calling out the national
guard right now
why didn't they do that on the night in
question it was day three of the riots
yeah i could understand why night one
they were totally unprepared outnumbered
weren't ready for this i get it night
two it was the same thing
the riot was continuing i don't have an
explanation as to why i just know a lot
of people that were local that during
that time were asking the same questions
where's law enforcement in this they
seem to be outnumbered they seem to be
really not taking care of this the way
that they should now let us remind
ourselves this was 2020 in the midst of
the race riots where police officers and
police departments were probably afraid
to do anything especially even portland
that's a whole other story where
portland police had literally had their
hands tied behind their backs they
couldn't they have riot training and
they weren't even allowed to do it
because they
the mayor wasn't allowing them because
they didn't want to cause any more race
riots even though they were just
continuing so i don't i i'm not saying
that's what happened in kenosha but i
this was kind of like the mentality in
2020 with police departments so i have
no idea it wasn't the mentality there
was there was police departments told to
stand down yeah and they stood down
based on those orders and they said well
let the city burn uh we're given
specific orders we're not going to
intervene and we're just going to watch
a lot of this happen and they did so
that aspect of it is the
crazy chilling aspect that should be
remembered let's do one more it's a
really important one richard thabod uh
thibaud says binger aimed the gun at the
jury to bait the defense he was trying
to get a reaction and a response out of
richard's it's good that richards didn't
fall for it that's a good point
interesting if he aimed to go to the
jury and the defense said whoa whoa you
can't do that bingo would have been like
oh i'm sorry i'm just doing what your
defendant did
you take objection to what i was doing
but you're claiming that what he did
wasn't wrong it was smart not to react
literally yes but okay i still think
it's crazy that the taliban has better
trigger discipline than a state
prosecutor
it's it's just ridiculous that we're at
this level and who knows whether this
was 3d chess i don't agree i think yeah
this guy
winging the thing
and didn't know what he was doing and
had you know a scary uh assault rifle
called a rifle again because jesus here
in his hands and wanted to play up on
the drama and emotions of it we went to
a range this is a while ago it was
probably beginning of this was probably
la almost last year and i had an ak and
i immediately picked it up and went like
that with my elbow and luke was like
yeah chicken wing out of here and i was
like well he's like paulie i was like oh
yeah sorry i got it
i gotta i gotta get more practice but
that was a while ago i've done better i
was with uh we went to the range with uh
forrest cooper from recoil he gave me a
lot of good pointers really really
helped improve my accuracy with the
handgun and with the rifle and stuff he
knows what he's doing yeah practicing is
important and it's a lot of fun
knowledge yeah when he explained to me
certain basics it really i was like oh
wow like these are things like i just
needed to hear one time i need to master
but it really does he is fantastically
knowledgeable he was helping me he was
teaching me all about door breaches and
the different types of door breaches
that they would use
incredibly great just fantastic
information had them last week check out
the show from friday my friends if you
haven't already smash that like button
subscribe to this channel share the show
with your friends is always the most
important thing you do really take the
url post it wherever you can because
that's how we make the show bigger
that's how we grow and i'm greatly
appreciative for all for all the support
you guys give us go to timcast.com
become a member because we got to hire
two more reporters we got to get two
more journalists we got we're trying to
just increase the amount of reporting we
do and i'll tell you this it's a major
investment for us because straight news
reporting
is hard to monetize if we did you know
so when i do my youtube segments it's my
opinion and analysis so i've got like my
my opinion bias headlines and everything
that does really well for me but for a
news organization is what i'm we're all
investing in with your membership we do
more straightforward headlines they're
less baity it's just we want to get the
facts and the truth it's really hard to
monetize so we're just basically
investing in this because we believe in
it and we need it as a member you help
that mission uh become complete and for
that we're gonna give you a members only
segment so make sure you subscribe but
don't forget you can follow the show at
tim cast irl and follow us on instagram
because we put up clips from the show
they're much much shorter they're
shareable they're great and well
instagram's hard to share but they're
like you know easy to understand and
digest regular people you can follow me
at tim cast on instagram or wherever
else drew you want to shout out your
show or anything yeah you guys could uh
follow my work on twitter drew h live uh
follow me on youtube drew hernandez i'm
on getter druih live instagram drew
hernandez live and those are all my
socials go check out my store my merch
store at drewhlive.com and that's how
you guys could support me i want to
shout out the commentators because
someone just wrote goldbinger and
the comments are absolutely amazing i
have the screen right in front of me i
love reading them i love interacting
with you guys and uh
yeah i mean the idea behind the shirt
that i'm wearing right now is that you
either trust history or you trust the
government you can't do both and you can
get this shirt and support me on the
best political shirts dot com and i'm
gonna have a pretty big announcement
tomorrow on luke uncensored dot com with
a very special offer to all of you guys
which i think is going to be really
great hope to see some of you guys there
i can also confirm the chat is excellent
i finally have a chance to sit next to
luke and shout out and there's they're
still putting one in the chat
drew freaking hernandez ladies and
gentlemen it's great to have you here
man the people have spoken that's right
it's true yeah i'm ian crossland check
me out on the internet ian crossland.net
catch you later thank you guys all so
much for tuning in to our awesome austin
tour i just came up with that and i'm
going with it tonight was fantastic
thank you so much for coming drew and
it's only going to get even more awesome
over the course the rest of the week so
excited so glad to be here in austin you
guys might follow me on twitter at
sourpatchlids
we got some crazy stuff planned and
tomorrow oh gosh
one of our guests was like we're gonna
break the internet and i'm like well
i don't i don't i don't say that i'm you
know but i kind of think so it's we're
gonna have seven people through your
party it's gonna be in austin it is an
austin battle royale oh my gosh it is
going to be a cacophony of crazy voices
so i hope you're ready for tomorrow and
i hope
this rv doesn't collapse under the
weight of the heavyweights that are
coming in for for the show so thank you
all so much for hanging out we'll see
you all in the member segment at
timcast.com thanks for being members
we'll see you there
you